SHOOT ME GOOD MORNING ONE
MINUTE. I DID THE ONE MINUTE.
AT PRIME MINISTER TO. TWO SURE
WE DO WE STILL NEED A MINUTE OR
WEAKENED. NINE GOOD MORNING IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVERT
NINETEEN- AND DEMOCRATS URGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC- ARE
WONDERFUL STAFF AND
LEGISLATORS. WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN IN
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO OUR NORMAL
PRACTICES. IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS CAN BE
FOLLOWED AND ALLOW. WE WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY VIA TELEPHONE. FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPATION TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED. ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT ON NOW.
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE.
964-844-2916 THREE FOUR FOUR
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. NINE
SIX THREE ZERO TWO FOUR. I'M
SORRY LET ME GO BACK THANK YOU
JERRY. 844-291-6364 WE SAY THAT
ONE MORE TIME. PHONE NUMBERS
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. NINE SIX THREE
FIVE ONE ONE THREE AGAIN THE
FIVE ONE ONE THREE. FOR INCH.
ON HOW TO TELL THE
TELECONFERENCES TO MARCH.
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND-
COMMITTEE WEBSITE- WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL
BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR WHO
WILL ACTUALLY TO DIAL ONE THEN
ZERO FOR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION.
PRESS THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND
WAIT PATIENTLY FOR THE OPERATOR
TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER
THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT SO
PLEASE BE PATIENT AND FOLLOW
THE MODERATORS PROMPTED ONE TO
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE. FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
ON MUTED AND HE WILL BE READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY CAN TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY SO WHEN YOU
START TO TALK OR WHEN YOU
NUMBER COMES UP TURN OFF THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
PROCEEDINGS ON BECAUSE THEN YOU
WON'T HAVE FEEDBACK AND WILL BE
ABLE TO HEAR YOU. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE GET YOUR
VOICE ON IN CONVERT BY FEEDBACK
I'LL OBVIOUSLY TRY TO MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARINGS AS
IS CUSTOMARY AND INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICER HAVE. THE
COMMUNICATIONS. MUTED IT IS
ALSO GOOD TIME REMIND EVERYONE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY THAT THIS
IS A FISCAL COMMITTEE. FOR ME
SEVEN AGAIN THIS IS A FISCAL
COMMITTEE SO PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
TESTIMONY TO THE PHYSICAL
ASPECTS OF THE BILL. YOUR
TESTIFYING ON WE'RE NOT GONNA
BE RE LITIGATING THE POLICY OF
THE BILL JUST TALKING ABOUT THE
FISCAL IMPLICATIONS. WHILE
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE HEARING PROCESSING
CONDUCTOR HEARINGS IN THIS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS OR
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW. USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE PATIENT WITH A OF US
DOING. TO THE BEST WE CAN AND
WE'RE TRYING TO ACCOMMODATE THE
PUBLIC AS BEST WE CAN. WE HAVE
THIRTY TWO BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA ALL OF WHICH ARE
SUSPENSE CANDIDATES. MOST OF
THE AUTHORS HAVE WAIVED
PRESENTATION. BUT WE WILL HAVE
EVERY BILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR PUBLIC TESTIMONY. WHETHER
AUTHORS HERE TO PRESENT TO
THEIR DOT THERE WILL BE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY. BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATIONS SO LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM MR SECRETARY
WOULD YOU CALL THE ROLL. CENTER
PORTANTINO I'M HERE. PORTANTINO
HERE BATES. BATES HERE BRADFORD
HELLO YOU'RE STILL HERE JONES
JONES HERE LEYVA YOUR LEYVA
HEREBY CASKEY- CASKEY HERE SIX
MEMBERS PRESENT. ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE SIX WE'RE GOING TO PROCEED
WE HAVE A QUORUM WILL BE MOVING
TO THE AGENDA IN FILE ORDER BUT
ALL BILLS ARE BY THE AUTHOR SO
ONCE WE TAKE UP AN AUTHOR WILL
DO ALL THE BILLS BY THAT AUTHOR
BUT IN THE FINAL ORDER AS WE
GET TO AUTHORS. THE COMMITTEES
OF WEBSITE IS W. W. W. DOT S.
A. P. R. DOT SENATE DOT CA DOT
GOV. IF ANY OF THE MEMBERS
PUBLIC WANT TO FOLLOW ALONG ON
THIS AGAIN W. W. W. DOT. S. A.
P. R. DOT SENATE DOT CA DOT G.
O. V. THE CONSTRAINTS REGARDING
THE LENGTH OF THE HEARING
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATION
INCLUDING PHONE CALLS. I'M WILL
LIMIT PUBLIC TESTIMONY- TO THE
PRIMARY WITNESSES TO TWO
MINUTES EACH AND THEN EVERYONE
ELSE WILL BE LIMITING THEIR FOR
TESTIMONY TO THEIR NAME THE
ORGANIZATION AND THEIR
POSITION- I'M GOING TO HOLD TO
THAT. POLICY SO PLEASE.
RESPECTED AS WELL AND WE WILL
GO TO OUR FIRST BILL. I THANK
YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE THIS
MORNING- WE'RE GONNA TRY TO GET
THROUGH AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
OUR FIRST BILL IS AB SEVENTY BY
MR BERMAN. AND CALIFORNIA
PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY
EDUCATION- AND MR BERMAN IS WAY
PRESENTATION AGAIN AS ALL OF
THE AUTHORS HAVE DONE TODAY. SO
IT'S TIME FOR SUPPORT TESTIMONY.
SO THERE'S ANYBODY WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY
NOW IS YOUR TIME. THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE IS
NOBODY IN ROOM. ONE TWELVE AND
SO MODERATOR WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
AB. SEVENTY GENTLEMEN THANK YOU
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTY. YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE KEY PAD
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER EIGHTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD LINE NUMBER EIGHT NINE.
IN MY NUMBER EIGHTY NINE WE DO
HAVE THE LINE OPEN FOR YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK. OKAY WE'RE
NOT GETTING A RESPONSE THERE
WILL MOVE ON TO MY NUMBER
NINETY THAT FLYING NINE ZERO.
THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS INYO CANDLE CRIED THERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LOW
INCOME CONSUMER COALITION WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY.
THANK YOU ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
ANYONE ELSE. THERE'S ONE MORE
PERSON- WE ARE JUT PROVIDING
THEIR LINE NUMBER I THANK YOU
MY NUMBER ONE ZERO EIGHT THE
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NUMBER ONE OH EIGHT WE HAVE THE
LINE OPEN FOR YOU. MISTER JONES
I DID. OKAY WE DO HAVE LINE ONE
ZERO EIGHT OPEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK LINE ONE ZERO EACH. OKAY
WE DO NOT HAVE A RESPONSE AND
ONE ZERO EIGHT I'LL CHECK ONCE
AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OF AB SEVENTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AGAIN TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. OF AB SEVENTY YOU WILL
PRESS ONE THEN IF ZERO ON THE
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. YES NO ONE
QUEUING UP PLEASE CONTINUE. ALL
RIGHT NOW IS THE TIME FOR
OPPOSITION HE WOULD LIKE TO
POSE AB SEVENTY THIS IS YOUR
CHANCE TO SPEAK. THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM WISHING TO SPEAK
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE WISHING TO
OPPOSE AB SEVENTY. IF YOU WISH
TO OPPOSE AB SEVENTY YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN IF ZERO. AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE A. B.
SEVENTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN.
ZERO NO ONE QUEUING UP PLEASE
CONTINUE. ALL RIGHTS THE
CONCLUDES OUR PUBLIC COMMENT
PERIOD THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE GOOD MORNING HOW ARE
YOU. MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AND DOING WELL THANK
YOU HOPE YOU ARE AS WELL-
PLEASE DON'T HAS CONDITION WE
DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON THIS
BILL OF THAT WOULD NOTE THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ESTIMATES IT WILL INCUR GENERAL
FUND COSTS. IN THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS I WOULD
NOTE THAT WE ANTICIPATE THE
ACTUAL NUMBER OF INSTITUTIONS
TO BE IMPACTED BY THIS BILL TO
BE SMALL. I AM INTERESTED IN
THE DEPARTMENT WILL LIKELY
REQUIRE FEWER RESOURCES THAN
IDENTIFIED. ADDITIONALLY THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER.
INDICATES THE BILL WILL LIKELY-
INVITE MINIMAL ENFORCEMENT
COST. AT WHICH WOULD BE MINOR
AN OBSERVABLE. LASTLY AT THE
BILL AND COULD RESULT IN
ADDITIONAL COURT CASES- HOWEVER
UNLESS PARTICULAR CASE IT
BECOMES SIGNIFICANT. AND CAN BE
DOCUMENTED THAT IT IS LIKELY TO
BE ABSORBED. THANK YOU SEEING
NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SEVENTY WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE DURING DEVI TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR ALSO BY MR
BERMAN. NOW IS THE TIME FOR
SUPPORT TESTIMONY. THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM IN THIS IS
ON THE CALIFORNIA STATE LOTTERY
FUNDS THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE WHO WANTS TO
SUPPORT. AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY
FOUR. EIGHT HUNDRED IF YOU WISH
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY EIGHTY FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ADVANTAGE ZERO AGAIN
FOR SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. NO ONE IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE. ALL RIGHT NOW
IS THE TIME FOR OPPOSITION
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY FOUR THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE. MODERATOR IS
THERE ANYONE. ON THE PHONE LINE
WISHING TO OPPOSE AB. TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR. IF YOU WISH
TO OPPOSE AB TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN IF ZERO. AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO OPPOSE AB TWENTY EP FOR YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO
EVERYONE QUEUING UP PLEASE
CONTINUE ALL RIGHT. DID I DO
THAT WAS SUPPORT RIGHT. I'M
SORRY IF THAT IS CORRECT ALL
RIGHT DEPARTMENT FINANCE. THANK
YOU THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
ESTIMATES THE BILL COULD CREATE
A NON LOCAL COST PRESSURES. ON
A COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS
AVAILABLE LOTTERY FUNDS
HOWEVER- WE WOULD NOTE THAT TO
THE EXTENT THAT COLLEGES USE
THESE FUNDS FOR HOUSING
ASSISTANCE AND FOOD ASSISTANCE-
THAT EXISTING PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND COULD
BE REDIRECTED TO SUPPORT OTHER
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PRIORITIES. I
WOULD NOTE THAT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE LOTTERY COMMISSION
ESTIMATES NO FISCAL OUR
PROGRAMMATIC COSTS AS A RESULT
OF THIS BILL. SEEING NO HANDS
GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING TO
MISTER RAMOS SHE IS WAY
PRESENTATION ON AB TWO SEVEN
FIVE NATIVE AMERICAN CULTURE
PRESERVATION- NOW'S THE TIME
FOR SUPPORT IS THERE ANYONE IN
THIS ROOM KNOWS OR ANYONE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE. NO IS THERE
ANYONE ONLINE MODERATOR WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT. AB TWO
SEVEN FIVE. IF YOU WISH TO
SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN. ZERO
AND IT WOULD BE A MOMENT. FOR
AB. TWO SEVEN FIVE. AND WE'RE
GOING TO LINE UP NUMBER ONE
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT THAT TWO
SEVEN FIVE. YOUR NAME. ADAM
KURZEN THANK YOU. IT WOULDN'T
WORK. MODERATOR. AND ONCE AGAIN
IF HE WISHED TO. SUPPORT AB TWO
SEVEN FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN. ZERO WE HAVE NO OTHER. WE
HAD NO. ONE SO WHAT SHE SAID. I
COULD WE HAVE NO OTHER THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT NOW IS THE TIME.
TO MOVED OPPOSITION TO OPPOSE
AB TWO SEVENTY FIVE NOW IS YOUR
CHANCE THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM AT THE MICROPHONE NO ONE
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
WISHING TO OPPOSE AB TWO
SEVENTY FIVE. IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE AB TWO SEVEN FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND
WE'LL GO TO LINE UP. WHAT ONE
THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS HERE AND READ
REPRESENTING GREAT AND
RANCHERIA I IN SUPPORT OF-
BOMBERS BILL AB. TWO SEVEN
FIVE. ANYONE WISHING TO OPPOSE.
IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE AB TWO
SEVEN FIVE ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AND NOT JUST BE ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. WE'LL GO TO LINE AND
LINE. ONE SEVENTEEN. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY NAME IS LEE DOUGLAS
NINE. TWO SEVEN FIVE. WE HAVE
NO OTHER. ALL RIGHT BERMAN
FINANCE. THE NATIVE AMERICAN
HERITAGE COMMISSION INDICATES
NO COST TO IMPLEMENT THIS BILL
AND POTENTIAL FOR COST SAVINGS
OVER TIME DUE TO A DECREASE IN
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH
REGULATIONS AND PROCESS
DEVELOPMENT. CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY INDICATES THAT IT IS
UNCLEAR WHETHER THE BILL WOULD
REQUIRE THE CAMPUS IS TO HIRE
AT LEAST ON WHICH RESULT IN
ADDITIONAL COST PRESSURES. THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SYSTEM
INDICATES THE BILL MAY RESULT
IN COSTS AND COST PRESSURES
ASSOCIATED WITH INCREASED
ADMINISTRATIVE WORKLOAD AND
MORE CHALLENGING PROCEDURES. WE
WOULD NOTE THAT SEVERAL
COMPONENTS OF THIS BILL DO
ALIGN WITH THE RECENTLY ADOPTED
YOU SEE INTERNET AMERICAN
GRAVES PROTECTION AND
REPATRIATION ACT POLICY. OF THE
FINAL VERSION OF WHICH WILL BE
ADOPTED LATER THIS YEAR. THANK
YOU FOR SAYING NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TWO
SEVENTY FIVE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVIE UNDER MR MAYES.
HE'S WAY PRESENTATION AB FOUR
NINE NINE. NOW IS THE TIME FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT IF SUPPORTERS OR
ANYONE HERE IN SUPPORT THERE'S
NO ONE HERE IS ANYONE EVER WON
TWELVE NO. OPERATOR'S OR ANYONE
OUR MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
LINE IN SUPPORT OF AB. FOUR
NINE NINE ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE. IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB. FOUR NINE NINE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO IN SUPPORT. WE HAVE
NO ONE THAT HAS QUEUED UP ALL
RIGHT NOW IS THE TIME FOR
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSED OR SOMEONE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE IS OR ANYONE
MODERATOR ON THE PHONE LINE
WISHING TO OPPOSE A BI FOUR
NINE. NINE IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE AB FOUR NINE NINE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. BUT WE HAVE
NO ONE THAT HAS OPPOSED ALL
RIGHT BERMAN FINANCE. THANK YOU
BASED ON THE FISCAL ANALYSES WE
RECEIVED FROM VARIOUS STATE
AGENCIES WOULD ESTIMATE THE
STATEWIDE COST OF THIS BILL TO
BE IN THE LOW MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME COSTS.
ADDITIONALLY OF A LARGE STATE
ENTITIES SUCH AS THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT IS
UNABLE TO CONFORM WITH ITS
PRACTICES AND REQUIREMENTS OF
THIS BILL THAT JANUARYFIRST
TWENTY TWENTY THREE THE COST OF
THIS BILL MAYES BE
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER. AS A
RESULT OF PROCURING IDENTITY
THEFT PREVENTION AND MITIGATION
SERVICES FOR AT LEAST TWELVE
MONTHS. THANK YOU SEE NO HANDS
GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION A
BEFORE NINETY NINE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVIE ON THIS TO CALL
THEIR OWN HAS TO BILLS HE'S WAY
PRESENTATION ON BOTH. AB FIVE
EIGHTEEN NOW IS THE TIME FOR
SUPPORT. FOR ANYONE IN THIS
ROOM WISHING TO SUPPORT AB FIVE
EIGHTEEN SEEING NO ONE WILL
MOVE TO ROOM ONE TWELVE THERE'S
NO ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE WISHING TO SUPPORT
AB FIVE EIGHTEEN BY MISTER
CALDERON. DEALING WITH SOUTHERN
YOUTH YOU WISH TO SUPPORT. AB
FIVE ONE EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. WE HAVE NO ONE
THAT HAS. INDICATED IN SUPPORT
ALL RIGHT NOW IS THE TIME FOR
OPPOSITION IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
OPPOSE SB FIVE EIGHTEEN HOW IS
YOUR CHANCE TO SPEAK THERE'S NO
ONE IN THIS ROOM IS NOW IN A
ROOM ONE TWELVE BATRES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
WISHING TO OPPOSE SB FIVE
EIGHTEEN. IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE
AB FIVE EIGHTEEN PRESS ONE AND
THEN. ZERO WE HAVE NO ONE THAT
HAS QUEUED UP. ALL RIGHT
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. THANK YOU
THE BILL THEY RESULT IN ONE
TIME REVENUE TO THE STATE
HOWEVER THE BILL DOES
AUTHORIZED THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES TO SELL THE
PROPERTY FOR LESS THAN FAIR
MARKET VALUE I WOULD KNOW THAT
ANY ESTIMATE ESTIMATE PROCEEDS
IS PREMATURE PENDING AN
APPRAISAL AND ECONOMIC
EVALUATION I WHICH WILL BE
CONDUCTED IMPROVED BY TGS.
LASTLY THE GROSS PROCEEDS OF
THE PROPERTY SALE WILL BE USED
TO REIMBURSE DGS FOR ANY COSTS
OR EXPENSES INCURRED IN THE
DISPOSITION OF THE PROPERTY.
ALL RIGHTS YOU KNOW HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB FIVE
EIGHTEEN WITH A SUSPENSE MOVIE
ON THE AB. TWENTY NINE TWENTY
SIX ALSO BY MISTER CALDERON. ON
REFERRAL AGENCIES FOR
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES.
NOW IS THE TIME FOR SUPPORT
THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS ROOM
WISHING THIS TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY NINE
TWENTY SIX THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM ONE ONE TWELVE. MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
WISHING TO SUPPORT AB. TWENTY
NINE TWENTY SIX. IF YOU WISH TO
SUPPORT AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY
SIX PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AND WE WILL GO TO THE LINE OF
EIGHTY FOUR. MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS BOB NAYLOR REPRESENTING
SIX BEDS CAN CAN ASSOCIATION OF
TWO THOUSAND ASSISTED LIVING
AND ADULT RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES. THANKS TO.
AMENDMENTS TAKEN BY THE AUTHOR
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AB TWENTY
NINE TWENTY SIX THANK YOU.
WE'LL GO TO LINE THEM NUMBER.
ONE FORTY FOUR. HI THIS IS A
QUOTE BURKE IN BEHALF OF A
PLACE FOR MOM ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS THE BILL WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT. THIS LEGISLATION WHICH
IS MORE IMPORTANT DURING CODED
TO ASSIST FAMILIES IN FINDING
OUT ABOUT. SO EASE IN WHICH
THEY ARE PLACING FAMILY MEMBERS
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. WE HAVE NO
OTHERS IN Q. ALL RIGHT NOW IS
THE TIME FOR OPPOSITION YOU'D
LIKE TO POST TWENTY NINE TWENTY
SIX THIS IS YOUR OPPORTUNITY
THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS ROOM IF
SOMEBODY IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE WISHING TO OPPOSE AB
TWENTY NINE TWENTY SIX.
SPROCKET BE WISH TO OPPOSE AB
TWENTY NINE TWENTY SIX PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE HAVE NO
ONE OPPOSED. ALL RIGHT.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE. ACCORDING
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL GENERAL FUND
RESOURCES TO LESS THAN TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR
THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES ESTIMATES ACOSTA BE
MINOR AN OBSERVABLE. THANK YOU
SEE NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB TWENTY NINE
TWENTY SIX WE GOT A SUSPENSE.
MOVIE MAYBE SIX SIXTY BY MISTER
MILLIE MR LEVINE. AND PERSONAL
INTEREST INFORMATION AND
CONTACT TRACING NOW'S YOUR TIME
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF AB SIX
SIXTIES WAY PRESENTATION-
THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE- MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE. WISHING TO
SUPPORT A. B. SIX SIXTY. IF YOU
WISH TO SUPPORT EIGHTY SIX
SIXTY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
WE WILL GO TO LINE OF NUMBER
NINETY. WITH. LINE NINETY YEAR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR MEMBERS DANIEL KENDALL HI
SIR ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LOW INCOME CONSUMER COALITION
IN SUPPORT OF AB. SIX SIXTY. WE
HAVE NO OTHERS IN Q. ALL RIGHT
NOW IS THE TIME PROPOSITIONS.
SB SIX SIXTY THERE'S NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSED OR SOMEONE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
WISHING TO OPPOSE A BI SIX
SIXTY. IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE AB
SIX SIXTY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO
CAROLINA NUMBER TWENTY NINE.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS PAUL YODER- ON BEHALF
OF THE TULARE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN MADERA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
OPPOSITION TO SB. SIX SIXTY. WE
HAVE NO OTHERS IN Q. ALL RIGHT
BERMAN FINANCE. IMPERMANENT
JUSTICES PUBLIC RIGHTS DIVISION
AND JUST FACE AN INCREASE IN
ENFORCEMENT WORKLOAD WITH COST
OF NINE HUNDRED TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND ONE
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AND I'M GOING. ALL RIGHT SINGLE
HANDS GO UP FOR THAT OBJECT
OBJECTION AB SIX SIXTY. WILL GO
TO THE SPORTS MOVING TO AB
SEVEN NINETY THREE BY MISTER
KING. ON RECYCLING PLASTIC
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS HE'S WAY
PRESENTATION. NOW SO TIME FOR
SUPPORT FOR ANYONE HERE WISHING
TO SUPPORT AB SEVEN NINETY
THREE NATIONAL CHANCE THERE'S
NOBODY IN THE ROOM. THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE WISHING TO SUPPORT
AB SEVEN NINETY THREE. IF YOU
WISH TO SUPPORT AB SEVEN NINETY
THREE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
DON'T BE JUST ONE MOMENT ONCE
AGAIN ONE AND THEN ZERO IN
SUPPORT. WE'LL GO TO LINE OF
SEVENTY FOUR. MY NAME IS
KATHLEEN GALLON ENABLING YOU TO
SUPPORT THE BILL PLEASE. WE
HAVE NO OTHERS THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT NOW IS THE TIME FOR
OPPOSITION DAVEY SEVEN NINETY
THREE BY MR TANG TWENTY ONE IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSE NO SORRY ONE
ROOM ONE TWELVE KNOWS ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE THAT IS OPPOSED
TO AB. SEVEN NINETY THREE. IF
YOU'RE OPPOSED TO AB SEVEN
NINETY THREE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. BUT WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q.
THE- THIS BILL MAY RESULT IN A
LOSS OF GENERAL FUND REVENUES
BY STOPPAGE ESTABLISHING A
SEPARATE FUND FOR THE DEPOSIT
OF PENALTIES ARE THE AMOUNT IS
UNKNOWN AT THIS TIME I COUNTY
CYCLE ESTIMATES COST OF THREE
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
I'M GOING COST OF TWO POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING
FUND- ASSOCIATED WITH THIS BILL.
LASTLY THE DEPARTMENT JUSTICE
ESTIMATES COSTS ABOUT FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS- TO ASSIST CAL
RECYCLE WITH POTENTIALLY
PURSUING ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS.
THANK YOU SEE NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SEVEN
NINETY THREE WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE- PLEASE SIR FOR
EVERYONE OUT THERE WHO'S
WANTING TO TESTIFY. WE'RE HAPPY
TO HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT-
THERE'S A TOLL FREE TELEPHONE
NUMBER AND IT'S EIGHT FOUR
FOUR.1-116-364-8442. NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR AND THERE'S
AN ACCESS CODE FOR TODAY'S
MEETING THAT IS NINE SIX THREE.
613-963-5113 SO YOU CAN GET OUR
INFORMATION OFF OUR COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE OR YOU COULD FOLLOW
WHAT I JUST SAID- THERE'S ALSO
DISTRICT A DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES SYSTEM WORKS ON
THE WEBSITE- BASICALLY WHEN WE
MOVED TO THE ITEM YOU WANT TO
SPEAK THE MODERATOR WILL PROMPT
YOU TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO. FOR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION PRESS THIS
ONLY ONE TIME ND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU
A LINE NUMBER THIS CAN BE A
SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU RECEIVE
YOUR NUMBER. HE WILL WAIT IN
THE QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO
CALL YOUR NUMBER AT THE TIME
YOU WILL BE ON MUTED AND YOU
WILL BE ABLE TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE PLEASE NOTE THAT YOU
MUST TURN OFF THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE COMMITTEE. FROM
BECAUSE THAT WILL CREATE
FEEDBACK IF YOU DON'T TURN IT
OFF WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
HEAR YOU CLEARLY SO PLEASE TURN
OFF THE DEVICE. YOU'RE
LISTENING TO WHEN YOU START. TO
TALK TO US WE'RE MOVING TO MISS
CERVANTES WHO HAS. TWO BILLS.
SB SEVEN NINETY EIGHT AND AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTY- THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION ON BOTH BILLS. AND
WE'LL GO RIGHT INTO SEVEN
NINETY EIGHT FOR SUPPORT
TESTIMONY THIS IS ON MATERNAL
MENTAL HEALTH. THERE'S NO ONE
IN THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT
NATIONAL MONUMENT ROOM ONE
TWELVE. MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE WISHING TO
SUPPORT AB SEVEN NINETY EIGHT.
IF YOU WISH TO SUPPORT AB SEVEN
NINETY EIGHT PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO ONE TO
HAVE QUEUED UP. THE SAME. YES
WE HAVE NO ONE THAT HAS QUEUED
UP OKAY THANK YOU MOVING ON
OPPOSITION THERE'S ANYBODY
OPPOSED SB SEVEN NINETY EIGHT.
NO ONE IN THIS ROOM NO ONE IN
ONE TWELVE MODERATORS OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE. THAT IS
SUPPOSED AB. SEVEN NINETY
EIGHT. IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE AB
SEVEN NINETY EIGHT PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. WE HAVE NO ONE
THAT HAVE QUEUED UP ALL RIGHT
BERMAN FINANCE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE BECAUSE MANY OF
THE BILL'S PROVISIONS APPEAR TO
BE DUPLICATIVE EFFORTS IN
EXISTING PUBLIC HEALTH PROGRAMS
ADDITIONALLY IF IMPLEMENTED THE
BILL MAY IMPOSE A STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE FOR
UNKNOWN BUT POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT COST TO COUNTIES.
RIGHT TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
BILL'S PROPOSED PILOT PROGRAM.
OF PUBLIC HEALTH ESTIMATES COST
OF NINE HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. AND THEN
IN JANUARY THEREAFTER FOR THE
DURATION OF A PILOT PROGRAM.
RAGING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION. SB SEVEN NINETY
EIGHT WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING TO TWENTY THREE SEVENTY
ON- ACCESS AND FUNCTIONAL NEEDS
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AGREEMENT FOR
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT AND
TRANSPORTATION. AND YOUR CHANCE
TO SUPPORT AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE MODERATOR WISHING TO
SUPPORT AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY.
IF YOU WISH TO SUPPORT AB
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AGAIN FOR
SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. I HAVE NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU
NOW IS THE TIME PROPOSITIONS AB
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY THERE'S NO
ONE IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED TO AB
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE. WISHING TO OPPOSE
AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY. IF YOU
WISH TO OPPOSE AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY. YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
IF ZERO. AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO OPPOSE AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY. YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN.
ZERO NO ONE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE THANK YOU. DEPARTMENT
FINANCE TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY.
YES THE MARGINS INDICATES ANY
COSTS RESULTING FROM THIS BILL
WOULD BE MINOR AN OBSERVABLE
HOWEVER WE'VE BEEN AT THE BILL
COULD CREATE A REIMBURSABLE
STATE MANDATE. FOR COUNTIES TO
IMPLEMENT AGREEMENTS AND UPDATE
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT PLANS.
THANK YOU SEEN NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTY WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. LIMIT AB EIGHT NINETY
ON NURSE PRACTITIONERS BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD- HIS WAY
PRESENTATION. AND NOW IS THE
TIME FOR SUPPORT ANYBODY'S IN
THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT THERE'S NO
ONE HERE. SOMEONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE WISHING TO
SUPPORT AB. EIGHT NINETY.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO CHAU SUPPORT FOR E. B.
NINETY YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AGAIN FOR SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHT NINE ZERO YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON THE PHONE
KEYPAD IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT.
WHY NUMBER FORTY LINE FOUR ZERO
YOU MAY GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
MODEL NOT LIKE HAVE PUBLIC
AFFAIRS CALLING ON BEHALF OF
NAY ROCKRIDGE NAY CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU. KLEIN NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE
LINES AT ONE FORTY THREE YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
RECORD TURN MEMBERS MARIA WEBER
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY NINE LINE ONE THREE NINE
YOU MAY GO AHEAD. MR HERE HE
GARY COOPER REPRESENTING A AND
THEN HEALTHCARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB ONE R. EIGHT NINETY THANK
YOU. AND ONCE AGAIN FOR THE
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT NINE ZERO
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO TO
GET INTO THE QUEUE. I HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE. NOW IS THE TIME FOR
OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHT NINETY.
THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS ROOM WHO
WISHES TO OPPOSE AB EIGHT
NINETY THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE MODERATORS OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE WISHING TO
OPPOSE AB EIGHT NINETY. IF YOU
WISH TO OPPOSE AB EIGHT NINETY
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
AGAIN TO OPPOSE AB EIGHT NINE
ZERO YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN.
ZERO WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
NUMBER ONE THREE AND THIS IS
YOUR LIFE EIGHTY NINE ZERO- AND
I PUT IT PERSONALLY GIVE SOME
TOP. YES PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION. HI MY NAME IS DR
JONATHAN BALL OF ONE- I'M
EMERGENCY POSITION PART OF THE
NATION'S FOR THE PATIENT
PROTECTION OF ALL THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS
AND THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
EMERGENCY MEDICINE I OPPOSE AB
EIGHT NINE ZERO. PRINCIPLES OF
PATIENT SAFETY AS WELL AS THE
FISCAL IMPACT ON TAXPAYERS- A
QUICK BACKGROUND ON WHAT A
NURSE PRACTITIONER. AT THIS
THIS BILL ALLOW KNOCKED OUT. AT
THIS POINT WE'RE JUST TAKING
OPPOSITION. SO YOU OPPOSE A. B.
O. OKAY. I OPPOSE IT YOU I DO A
QUICK PLUG FOR A NUMBER OF
CONSIDERATIONS ARE NOW THANK
YOU. OKAY WE APPRECIATE YOUR
INTEREST THANK YOU. OKAY DID
YOU WANT ME TO MOVE ON YES.
THANK YOU ARE WE HAVE MY NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO LINE
AT ONE THREE TWO YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. AND ONE THIRTY TWO WE
HAVE THE LINE OPEN FOR YOU
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
DOCTOR GOMEZ FORM I FEW NURSE
NURSE PRACTITIONER NOW
EMERGENCY WAS DEFICIENT AND I
OPPOSE A. B. NINETY THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE LINE A NUMBER
SEVENTY THAT'S LINE SEVEN ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS ERIC PROPERLY ON A
MASTERCARD SAN DIEGO ON ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN DIEGO
PSYCHIATRIC. SOCIETY
REPRESENTING OVER THREE THREE
SEVENTY FIVE. AND GAVE UP AN
ACCOUNTING POSTED STILL. THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY TWO LINE AT ONE FOUR TWO
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS DR CHOI AND I'M A
PSYCHIATRIST IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSED
EIGHTY EIGHT NINETY THAT WITH
PLAYSTATION BUT DIRECT RISK OF
HARM THANK YOU. LINE NUMBER
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE TWO FIVE. I MEAN THE
DOCTOR SMITH AND THEN IN
PRIVATE PRACTICE AND I BELIEVE
THIS BILL. MY NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY NINE ONE
THREE ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
DOCTOR CAN MARKER I PRACTICE
INTERMITTENT SANTIAGO AND I
OPPOSE IT BE EIGHT NINETY. LINE
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY THREE
LINE ONE FIVE THREE YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. BRENT SPENCE ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
OBGYN STRYCHNINE IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
OPPOSE AB EIGHT NINE ZERO YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON THE
TELEPHONE KEYPAD AGAIN TO
OPPOSE AB EIGHT NINE ZERO YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON THE
PHONE KEYPAD. YOU JUST ONE
MOMENT. ONE ONE FIVE FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD ONE FIFTY FOUR.
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE ONE FIFTY
FOUR WE HAVE THE LINE OPEN FOR
YOU. AB DISCONNECTED WE'LL GO
TO LINE NUMBER EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE EIGHT SIX.
MORNING DOUG CHIPMAN STURGILL
IN ABOUT THE UNION OF AMERICAN
PHYSICIANS AND DENTISTS MONICA
MEMBERS WE ARE THE LARGEST
POSITIONS UNION IN THE COUNTRY
AND WE'RE ON STRONG OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL THANK YOU. NINE
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY SEVEN
LINE ONE FIVE SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES THIS IS SUMMER HERE
TO THE LEGISLATION FOR THE
BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING
AND- IRAQI TWO EIGHTY EIGHT
NINETY WE UP CLOSE AND LOOKED
INTO IT THANK YOU. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU OPPOSE AB EIGHT NINE
ZERO YOU MAY GET INTO THE PHONE
QUEUE BY PRESSING ONE THEN ZERO
IT'LL BE JUST ONE MOMENT. ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE ONE FIVE SIX. GOOD
MORNING CARE MEMBERS PATHOLOGY
DOCTOR ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. I HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE FOR
OPPOSITION PLEASE CONTINUE ALL
RIGHT BERMAN FINANCE TELL US
ABOUT EIGHT NINETY. DEPARTMENT
OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS INDICATES
THE BILL WILL RESULT IN MINOR
OBSERVABLE COSTS TO THE BOARD-OF REGISTERED NURSING. HOWEVER
THERE MAY BE AN INCREASE IN-ENFORCEMENT COSTS TO THE EXTENT
IT IS NOT COMPLAINTS ARE MADE A
AND THE POTENTIAL INCREASE IN
COST IS UNKNOWN AT THIS TIME.
OF THE DEPARTMENT STATES THE
OCCUPATIONAL ANALYSIS REQUIRED
BY THIS BILL IS ESTIMATED TO
COST ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS EVERY FIVE
YEARS- BUT LIKELY THIS COST CAN
BE ABSORBED. THE DEPARTMENT OF
STATE HOSPITALS AND DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION- BOTH INDICATE
THAT THERE ARE TOO MANY UNKNOWN
FACTORS AT THIS TIME- TO
REVISE. AN ESTIMATED FISCAL
IMPACT. WITHOUT SPECIFIC
DETAILS ON EDUCATION EXPERIENCE
AND CERTIFICATION REQUIREMENTS
TO PRACTICE INDEPENDENTLY. OF
BOTH DEPARTMENTS ARE UNABLE TO
DETERMINE. HOW INDEPENDENT
NURSE PRACTITIONERS MAY BE
UTILIZED IN THEIR ENTITIES. ALL
RIGHT SEEING NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB EIGHT
NINETY WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING TO MR CHIU- A. B. ELEVEN
OH SEVEN. ON PROCLAIMED STATE
EMERGENCIES PROCLAMATIONS
MATERIALS AND ANNOUNCEMENTS- IS
WAY PRESENTATION. ON A. B.
ELEVEN OH SEVEN. WE WILL TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS TIME
THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. IS THERE ANYONE ONLINE
MODERATOR ON THE PHONE LINE
WISHING TO SUPPORT A. B. ELEVEN
OH SEVEN. IF YOU ARE SHOWING
SUPPORT FOR A BI ELEVEN OH
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. I HAVE NO ONE IN Q. FOUR
SUPPORT YOU MAY CONTINUE. THERE
WAS NO ONE ELSE. OKAY I HAVE A
ONE NO ONE ON THE PHONE ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOING OPPOSITION
THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS ROOM WHO
WISH ARE YOU HERE TO OPPOSE A.
B. ELEVEN OH SEVEN NOW. A. B.
ELEVEN OH SEVEN THERE'S NO ONE
IN THIS ROOM THERE'S NO ONE ON
THE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED AB ELEVEN OH SEVEN. IF
YOU WISH TO OPPOSE H. E. B.
ELEVEN OH SEVEN. YOU MAY GET
INTO THE QUEUE BY PRESSING ONE
THEN ZERO. AGAIN TO OPPOSE A.
B. ELEVEN OH SEVEN. YOU MADE
PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION QUEUING UP PLEASE
CONTINUE ALL RIGHT BERMAN
FINANCE TELL US ABOUT A. B.
ELEVEN OH SEVEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WERE OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE BECAUSE IT'S
LIKELY TO CREATE SIGNIFICANT
ONGOING GENERAL FUND COSTS-
WHILE THE TOTAL COST TO
IMPLEMENT ARE UNKNOWN- THEY
COULD BE IN THE RANGE OF. TENS
TO HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS DEPENDING ON THE
FREQUENCY AND DURATION OF
DECLARED EMERGENCIES. HI COSTS
WOULD BE FUNDED BY A VERY
SPECIAL FUNDS AND THE GENERAL
FUND. THANK YOU FOR USING THEIR
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB ELEVEN OH SEVEN. WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON THE A. B.
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX BY MR CHIU.
WHO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION ON
TENNESSEE. STATE OF EMERGENCY-
RELATED TO COVERT NINETEEN- HIS
WAY PRESENTATION OF THERE'S NO
ONE IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT. OF
AB FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX NOW IS
THE TIME FOR SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
MODERATOR PLEASE. OPEN UP
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. OF
AB FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX. IF YOU
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER NINETY PLEASE GO
AHEAD LET ME LINE NUMBER NINE
ZERO. GOOD MORNING DANIELLE CAN
OCCUR THERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION IN SUPPORT. MY NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE ONE
THREE FIVE YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING ROSS BARKLEY ON
BEHALF OF SACRAMENTO MAYOR
DARRELL STEINBERG IN SUPPORT.
MY NUMBER FOURTEEN MINUTE ONE
FOUR YOU MAY GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
GREGORY KRAMER ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT. MY NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE ONE FOUR
ZERO YOU MAY GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TO
MEET PAYROLL ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
MY NUMBER TWENTY NINE LINE TWO
NINE. MISTER CHAIRMAN A MEMBER
SPOILER ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX LINE
ONE THREE SIX YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS TO CALL ME TOMORROW
MAJORITY. ON BEHALF OF THE
POLITICIAN ARE LEADERS OF
TOMORROW GROUP FROM SUPPORT. BY
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
NINE NINE ONE SIX NINE YOU MAY
GO AHEAD. HELLO. HELLO HELLO
HELLO HELLO WHILE YOU'RE THERE
EXCELLENT I'M NEW TO THESE
TECHNOLOGIES. IT'S ABOUT
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX YES PLEASE
TAKE STATE YOUR NAME AND JUST
YOUR POSITION IN YOUR
ORGANIZATION THANK YOU. OKAY
YOU CAN HEAR ME EXCELLENT MY
NAME IS OPEN THE STATE. MY
AFFILIATION IS SAME ON THIS
LET'S JUST PUT. MOVE ON TO MY
NUMBER SIXTY SIX LINE SIXTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. REMEMBER TO
ENTER AND KRIEGER ON BEHALF OF
LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI
IN SUPPORT. OF AB ONE FOUR
THREE SIX AND ALSO ON THE CITY
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
BEVERLY HILLS. WE COULD CALL.
YOU HAVE MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND SIX LINE ONE ZERO SIX YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. WARNING THIS IS
TIFFANY WONG SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF STRATEGIC CONCEPTS IN
ORGANIZING AND POLITICAL
EDUCATION. OKAY BASED IN THE
SOUTH VALLEY COMMUNITY IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN SIX.
THANK YOU. WE MY NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THREE LINE
ONE SIX THREE YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS JIM
LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
NINE NINE ONE SIX NINE YOU MAY
GO AHEAD THE QUEUE IS THE- M.
T. LET ME CHECK ONE MORE TIME
IF YOU WISH TO SHOW SUPPORT OF
AB FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AGAIN FOR
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN THIRTY
SIX. YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. NO ONE IN THE QUEUE AT
THIS TIME PLEASE CONTINUE THANK
YOU NOW WILL GO TO OPPOSITION
OF AB FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX NOW
IS THE TIME TO. SHARE YOUR POST
POSITION OF AB FOURTEEN THIRTY
SIX THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM. THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE MODERATOR PLEASE
QUEUE UP THE FOLKS WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO AB.
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX. IF YOU
WISH TO OPPOSE AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO ONE
ONE SEVEN TWO YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CREAM GREASY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. NUMBER FORTY EIGHT LINE
FOUR ZERO YOU MAY GO AHEAD. THE
MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
RESEARCH AND NOT AND NOT LIKE
HAS PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF.
UNITY CALIFORNIA WITH THAT
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
AND WORK ENVIRONMENT AT THE
AUTHOR THANK YOU. MY NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY NINE NINE ONE
SIX NINETY MAY GO AHEAD. NINE
ONE SIXTY NINE WE HAVE THE LINE
OPEN. SB HELLO. MMHM. NEXT
PERSON PLEASE. THANK YOU. AGAIN
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO OPPOSE AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. LINE ONE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY NINE THE LINE IS OPEN YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. HELLO. THAT'S
FINE ONE SIXTY NINE. YOU MAY GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HIS
RELATIVES THE. THE LINES OPEN.
AND WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON UP FOR
THOSE FOLKS WHO HAVE NO ONE
ELSE MODERATOR HOLD ON I HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE OKAY
GREAT SO WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE
THE PUBLIC COMMENT ON- A. B.
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX BEFORE WE
GO TO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES
FOR FOLKS WHO ARE WISHING TO
TESTIFY. JUST STATE YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION WE CAN HEAR YOU WANT
TO THE PHONE LINE IS OPEN- WE
DON'T ACTUALLY NEED THE
SALUTATIONS JUST YOUR NAME YOUR
POSITION IN YOUR ORGANIZATION
THANK YOU. THE WAS IN THE.
CONSTRUCTIVE PERCENT OPPOSITION.
TO THAT WAS OPPOSITION TO I
BELIEVE YEAH YEAH. I. MODERATOR.
MODERATOR YES JUST FOR THE
RECORD OTHER THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE IN THE QUEUE ON FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX RIGHT I HAVE ONE
PERSON THAT JUST TO BACK UP DO
YOU WANT ME TO OPEN THE LINE
SURE. WE'LL TAKE THAT LAST
PERSON JUST TO MAKE SURE WE
FREE ACCOMMODATED EVERYONE ON
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX. OKAY WE'RE
GONNA OPEN THE LINE BACK UP FOR
MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
NINE THE LINE IS OPEN. ONE
SIXTY NINE. I'M ONE SIXTY NINE
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD MA'AM YOUR
NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION. MY NAME IS YOU CUT
OFF HUNDREDS OF CALIFORNIANS
YESTERDAY ABOUT THIS BILL MY
POSITION IS SHAME ON THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SHUTTING PEOPLE OUT
OF GOVERNMENT AND I DON'T
BELIEVE FOR ONE MINUTE THERE'S
NOT HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE ON THIS
LINE BECAUSE THERE CERTAINLY
WERE YESTERDAY. WONDERFUL MA'AM
WE'RE GONNA YOU'VE SAID YOUR
PEACE THANK YOU AND FOR THE
RECORD THIS COMMITTEE DID NOT.
NINETEEN THANK YOU THIS
COMMITTEE DID NOT MEET
YESTERDAY SO WE HAVE NOT SHUT
ANYONE OFF. I HAVE FOR THE
RECORD RE OPENED THIS. ISSUE I
THINK NOW THREE TIMES. TO SEE
IF THERE WAS ANY ADDITIONAL PER
PEOPLE WE LET YOU IN AND YOU
SAID YOUR PIECE WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE MAIN ACT. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR WE ESTIMATE
THE BILL WILL ADELINE ALONE
HOLD ON ONE SECOND LET ME JUST
CLARIFY. WE'RE GONNA TAKE A
THIRTY SECOND RECESS HOLD ON
ONE SECOND. THAT'S JUST IT
WROTE IT IT'S- WE GET. SO WE
WILL GO TO OUR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
WE ESTIMATE THE BILL WILL WILL
RESULT IN REDUCTIONS AND
UNLAWFUL DETAINER FOR
FORECLOSURE AND EDUCATIONS- BUT
THE BILL MAY ALSO RESULT IN AN
INCREASE IN PROCEEDINGS FOR
POTENTIAL VIOLATIONS OF THE
BILL'S PROVISIONS. TO EXTEND
THIS BILL RESULT IN ADDITIONAL
CIVIL ACTIONS IT COULD ADD TO
THE TRIAL COURT'S CASELOAD
WHICH WOULD INCREASE BACKLOGS
AND TO CREATE A GENERAL FUND
COST PRESSURE. WE WOULD NOTE
HOWEVER THAT COURTS ARE
TYPICALLY FUNDED ON A REGULAR
BASIS SO UNLESS THIS PARTICULAR
CASE LOAD BECOME SIGNIFICANT
CAN BE DOCUMENTED. IT IS LIKELY
TO BE ABSORBED. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN
THE- EFFORT TO BE EXTREMELY
DILIGENT IN MAKING SURE THAT
WE- HEAR FROM FOLKS ONLINE
MODERATOR. I WOULD OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINE BECAUSE WE
UNDERSTAND THERE ARE PEOPLE
ONLINE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
OPPOSE. AB FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX
SO I WILL RE OPEN THE PHONE
LINE. FOR AB FOURTEEN THIRTY
SIX FOLKS IF YOU ARE WISHING TO
TESTIFY ON FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX
PLEASE FOLLOW THE PROMPTS OF
THE MODERATOR. AND WE WILL
ACCOMMODATE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION.
SO MODERATOR.
NINE ONE NINE
ZERO THE HAVE REMOVED
THEMSELVES FROM THE QUEUE WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
ONE EAT EAT. HELLO PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND
YOUR POSITION. ALIANT JOB I AM
JUST A SMALL- MINORITY- AND I
I'M I'M IN OPPOSITION OF THIS I
DON'T THINK THANK YOU THERE ARE
ENOUGH SAFEGUARDS FOR AND WE'RE
JUST AT THIS POINT IN THE TEST.
OR THAT MA'AM AT THIS POINT IN
THE TESTIMONY WERE JUST TAKING
YOUR NAME AND YOUR POSITION AND
SO THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE YOU
BEING INVOLVED IN THANK YOU
WILL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT PERSON.
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND NINETY
LINE ONE NINE ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU CAN. THANK
YOU EMILY DEL ON THE HALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CREDIT UNION
LEAGUE IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
AGAIN FOR OPPOSITION OF AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. NO ONE IN
THE QUEUE FOR OPPOSITION YOU
MAY CONTINUE ALL RIGHT THAT IS
THE FIFTH TIME I BELIEVE WE'VE
TRIED TO ACCOMMODATE THE PUBLIC
WE'VE GOT AN EXTRA MILE AND I
THINK- THANK YOU TO OUR STAFF
FOR. MAKING SURE THAT EVERYONE
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY WHO WANTED
TO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY IN THE
MODERATE APPRECIATED- WE HAVE
TAKEN OUR COMMENTS FROM THE
PARMON OF FINANCE NOPE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS SO WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX WILL
MOVE TO THE SUSPENSE. FILE
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO AB
FIFTEEN OH SIX I'M GONNA TURN
OVER THIS TO MISS BATES. WILL
COME OVER HERE OUR OFFICE TEN
IN MY BOOK SHE STAY THERE. THIS
FEATURE VICE CHAIR. YES I JUST
FOLLOWED THAT MISS BATES OUR
VICE CHAIR WILL- TAKE OVER FOR
A WHILE AND- I WILL BE BACK
MISTAKES. WE ARE ON AB FIFTEEN
OF SIX I JUST NEED TO VOTE YEP.
OKAY THIS. ONE WE ARE BACK ON
FILE AND WE WILL RESTART WITH
AB FIFTEEN OH SIX FIREARM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY- POLICE
USE OF FORCE AYE HE HOUSE OF.
THIRTY IS NOT GOING 2% ALSO
WE'LL MOVE RIGHT INTO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. IS THERE
ANYONE ONE HERE IN THE ROOM I
DON'T SEE ANYONE COMING TO THE
MICROPHONE BUT WITNESSES IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE. WE DO NOT HAVE
ANY OUR MODERATOR IF YOU'D
PLEASE PROP THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB FIFTEEN OH SIX AND LET ME
KNOW HOW MANY THERE ARE. WHO
ARE WISHING TO TEST FIND
SUPPORT ON AB FIFTEEN OH SIX.
IF YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN OH SIX
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
ONE PERSON IN THE QUEUE THAT
FLIGHT NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE ONE THREE FIVE. GOOD
MORNING ROSS BARKLEY ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO IN
SUPPORT. AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIFTEEN OH SIX YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. I HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU MIRAMONTE
MODERATOR WE RIGHT NOW ARE YOU
ME I APOLOGIZE I DO HAVE
SOMEONE QUEUING UP I DO
APOLOGIZE WE'RE GETTING THEM
THE A LINE NUMBER ONE MOMENT.
THANK YOU. MMHM. I'LL JUST
REPEAT THE INSTRUCTION IF YOU
ARE SHOWING SUPPORT FOR A BI
FIFTEEN OH SIX YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND. FIVE
NINE TWO ZERO FIVE. NINE TWO
ZERO FIVE LINE IS OPEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK STE. HELLO OKAY
ARE YOU KNOW I. DIDN'T RECEIVE
A NUMBER OF BAD THOUGHT YOU
DON'T ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
OF CHILD AND ADOLESCENT
PSYCHIATRY AND CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. YOU
HAVE MY NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
NINE TWO ZERO NINE YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS STILL
STORED ON BEHALF OF SUMMER
STAFF AND THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
OF SAN DIEGO COUNTY WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN OH SIX
ALTHOUGH THE RECENT AMENDMENTS
ARE TROUBLING WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR ON
CLARIFYING LANGUAGE. THANK YOU.
AND I HAVE Y. NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE ONE FOUR
ZERO YOU MAY GO AHEAD. CAN GET
YOUR NUMBERS COMMUTER WALL ON
BEHALF OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT. AND I HAVE ONE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND ELEVEN
LINE TWO ONE ONE YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. REBECA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS.
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
AND AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SHOW
SUPPORT OF AB. FIFTEEN OH SIX
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
THE MOMENT PLEASE.
AND WE'RE
JUST GIVING THEM A LINE NUMBER
IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT. TWO
HUNDRED AND TEN LANE TWO ONE
ZERO YOU MAY GO AHEAD. PLEASE
GO AHEAD LINE TO TEN WE HAVE
THE LINE OPEN FOR YOU IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK. PINETREE
CHANNELING IS OPEN PLEASE CHECK
YOUR MUTE FEATURE. OKAY I WILL
CHECK ONE MORE TIME IF YOU ARE
SHOWING SUPPORT FOR AB ONE FIVE
ZERO SIX. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. I HAVE NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE FOR SUPPORT YOU MAY
CONTINUE. THANK YOU WILL NOW
USE THE SAME PROCESS FOR THE
OPPOSITION AND I DO NOT SEE
ANYONE HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO
THREE IN OPPOSITION- NOR IN
ROOM R. ONE TWELVE SO MODERATOR
IF YOU PLEASE PROP THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO AB FIFTEEN OH
SIX. POLICE USE OF FORCE BOB
PLEASE CONTINUE. IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE AB FIFTEEN OH SIX. YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. BY
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE. TWO ZERO
FOUR. WHAT YES PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING AND MEDICARE
MEMBERS WHO SHALL MUCH RAM YOU
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION
TO A DIFFERENT COLOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE AB FIFTEEN OH SIX YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. I HAVE
NO ONE IN THE QUEUE FOR
OPPOSITION YOU MAY CONTINUE.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
YOU HAVE A FILE. YES THANK YOU
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ESTIMATES COSTS OF THIRTY ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND IN. TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. FIFTY NINE POINT
SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TO SEVENTY
FIVE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE. EIGHTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR. AND
EIGHTY ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY THEREAFTER.
ADDITIONALLY BECAUSE IT'LL
REQUIRES A STATE PROSECUTOR TO
INVESTIGATE INCIDENTS OF OFFER
OFFICER INVOLVED USE OF FORCE
RESULTING IN THE DEATH OF AN
UNARMED CIVILIAN. ACTIVITIES
ARE COUNTY- MAKES THAT REQUEST
THIS BILL COULD CREATE A
STATEMENT PERSONAL MANDATE TO
LOCAL AGENCIES. TO REIMBURSE
PROSECUTORS FOR THESE
INVESTIGATIONS. THANK YOU
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS I DON'T
SEE ANY HANDS UP. IN THE END
WITH OBJECTION AB FIFTEEN OH
SIX AND IS THERE TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE. ARE NEXT ON BILL
ON THE FILE IS AB SIXTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO.
ELECTRONIC WILLS AND HE HAUSA
FONG SAID HE ON DON'T WANT TO
BE SO. IS THERE A HE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE FOUR SUPPORT.
HI DON'T SEE ANYONE COMING TO
THE MICROPHONE WITNESSES IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE CNN MODERATOR
IF YOU'LL PLEASE PROP THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF. AB SIXTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN ABOUT PLEASE CONTINUE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR A BI.
SIXTEEN SIXTY SEVEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE HAVE
ONE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
TWELVE LINE ONE ONE TWO YOU MAY
GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MARKUP PRAYER
ON BEHALF OF LEGALZOOM-
HEADQUARTERED IN GLENDALE
CALIFORNIA URGING YOUR SUPPORT
OF AB. SIXTEEN SIXTY SEVEN. IF
YOU WISH TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR A
BI SIXTEEN SIXTY SEVEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. I HAVE NO
ONE IN THE QUEUE FOR SUPPORT OF
AB SIXTEEN SIXTY SEVEN YOU MAY
CONTINUE. THANK YOU WILL NOW
USE THE SAME PROCESS FOR THE
OPPOSITION ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES PRESENT HERE IN THIS
ROOM SEEING NONE OF ROOM ONE
TWELVE SEEING NONE AND THEN WE
WILL MOVE TO THE PHONES AND
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MODERATOR IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE
YES THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE AB SIXTEEN SIXTY SEVEN.
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
THANK YOU TO BE JUST A MOMENT.
MY NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY EIGHT POINT TWO TWO
EIGHT YOU MAY GO AHEAD. A LINE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
EIGHT WE HAVE THE LINE OPEN FOR
YOU. A LINE TO TWENTY EIGHT
WE'RE NOT HEARING A RESPONSE IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK. CAME IN A
CLOSE THAT LINE. THE OF
DISCONNECTED I HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN THE QUEUE. THANK YOU ON
ANYTHING ON DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE CALIFORNIA LAW
REVISION COMMISSION ESTIMATES
ANY FISCAL IMPACT FROM THIS
BILL WOULD BE MINOR OBSERVABLE
ADDITIONALLY THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL INDICATES THIS BILL
WILL NOT CREATE ANY FISCAL
IMPACTS TO THEIR BRANCH. THANK
YOU MEMBERS I SEE NO HANDS UP
THEN WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY SEVEN IS MOVED TO
THE SUSPENSE FILE AN EXCITING
ON THE FILE AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
TWO ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO WHOSE
WAY PRESENTATION ARE YOU TO
SIGN UP CONTACT TRACING. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN THE ROOM
WHO. WISHES TO SUPPORT A C.
NINE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE I SEE
NONE MODERATOR I WOULD YOU
PLEASE PROPERTY INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT
OF AB. SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TWO. IF
YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TWO YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER NINETY THAT FLYING
NINE ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING DANIELLE CANDOR BECAUSE
HER ON BEHALF OF THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION PRIVACY
RIGHTS CLEARINGHOUSE AND COMMON
SENSE KIDS ACTION SUPPORT. WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THREE LINE TWO THREE
THREE YOU MAY GO AHEAD. DON
COMMITTEE ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
DERMATOLOGY AND DERMATOLOGIC
SURGERY IN OPPOSITION. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SHOW SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN
QUEUE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AGAIN THIS IS IN SUPPORT
OF AB. SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TWO. I
HAVE NO ONE IN THE SUPPORT
QUEUE AT THIS TIME PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU WILL GO ON
TO THE OPPOSITION MAIL. ORDER I
DIDN'T SEE NO ONE STEPPING TO
THE MICROPHONE HERE AND RAN
FORTY TWO OH THREE NINE NINE
AND ONE TWELVE POSSIBLE MADAM
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE
PROPERTY INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TWO. IF YOU
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TWO YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SEVENTY EIGHTY
TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
I HAVE NO ONE IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU AND
THANK YOU TO ALL OUR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE DO WE HAVE A FILE.
THANK YOU WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE BECAUSE IT COULD
POTENTIALLY CREATE SIGNIFICANT
GENERAL FUND COST PRESSURES
THAT WERE NOT CONSIDERED AS
PART OF THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET ACT. I WOULD NOTE THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
INDICATES INCREASED ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS RESULTING IN COST OF
FOUR HUNDRED FOURTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND SEVEN HUNDRED SIXTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND I'M
GOING FOR THE GENERAL FUND.
ACTUALLY THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM INDICATES.
ARE COSTS WOULD BE MINOR AN
OBSERVABLE. AND AT THE TIME OF
OUR ANALYSIS UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA WAS NOT ABLE TO
PROVIDE A FISCAL. Q. THANK YOU
MEMBERS I'D SEEN ALL HANDS UP.
THEN WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TWO YEARS
MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE FILE FAR
WE ARE MOVING ON TO AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM. ON
PESTICIDES ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BILLION HOUSE WAY PRESENTATION.
LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE ON
THE ON. ROOM FORTY TWO THREE AC
NO HANDS UP NO ONE AT THE
MICROPHONE ANYONE AND EVERYONE
CHAU WE HAVE NONE SO MODERATOR
IF YOU'D PLEASE PROMPT THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING. TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT. HE WAS TO TESTIFY
EIGHTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
NUMBER FIVE ONE THIS IS ROBERT
CRAMPTON IN PASADENA. I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I AM
AFFILIATED WITH POISON FREE
MALIBU. MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND SEVEN LINE ONE ZERO SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
BONNIE HALE I'M A FORMER
VETERINARY TECHNICIAN AND
WILDLIFE REHABILITATOR IN PALO
ALTO I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVEN LINE TWO ZERO SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE PRODUCT
THAT YOU'RE BEGINNING A LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. MY
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY
ONE LINE AT ONE FOUR ONE THREE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
NICHOLAS SACKETT REPRESENTING
SOCIAL COMPASSION IN
LEGISLATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER FORTY NINE FOUR
ZERO YOU MAY GO AHEAD. OKAY OUR
SYSTEM AUTOMATICALLY ALL PUBLIC
AFFAIRS CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE ANIMAL LEGAL DEFENSE FUND
THAT PRAGUE BONTA DEVELOPED
PART. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN LINE ONE
ONE FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS ADAM GERGEN SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THE MAJORITY OF
WILDLIFE REHABILITATOR AND I'M
SUPPORT OF. THIS BILL. I HAVE
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY EIGHT LINE ONE SEVEN
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. JERRY
FOREVER SAVE L. A. COUGARS
SUPPORT AB. SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT. NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY ONE AT LINE TWO FOUR ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
JENNIFER **** I LIVE IN SANTA
BARBARA CALIFORNIA AND I'M
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT. BY
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
LANE TWO ONE FIVE YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS TINA ROSE
MARINO I AM CALLING ON BEHALF
OF STATE ACTUALLY CANYON WE ARE
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THIS AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. LINE NUMBER FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE FOR FIVE.
NUMBER FORTY FIVE YOU MAY GO
AHEAD WE HAVE THE LINE OPEN.
LEVINE ADDED TO THE NEXT
PERSON- THAT IS MY NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE NINE ONE
SIX ONE YOU MAY GO AHEAD. I AM
CONSTRUCTION I VOLUNTEER WITH
THE GOLDEN GATE RAPTOR
OBSERVATORY AND I SUPPORT AB.
ONE SEVEN EIGHT EIGHT. MY
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
EIGHT YOU MAY GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS ANDREA STRONG I'M A
VOLUNTEER WITH THE SANTA
BARBARA WILDLIFE CARE NETWORK I
AM READY DURING MY- BOTH OF
SUPPORT FOR THE SB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU. I
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
LINE TWO TWO ZERO YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. I MILLION KURODA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB. SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT. WHY NUMBER NINETY
TWO LINE NINE TWO YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. HI KERRY THOUGHT CA A
MEMBER OF THE CAR THEIR
NEIGHBOR COUNSELING NEIGHBOR
ACCOUNT ASSEMBLY ALLIANCE
CALLING ON BEHALF OF MYSELF I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND SIX LINE
TWO ZERO SIX YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME FOR FEAR AFTER
COLUMBUS THE PLANNING
CONSERVATION LEAGUE AND WE ARE
IN THE SUPPORT OF THE SPELL. MY
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THREE LINE ONE EIGHT THREE YOU
MAY GO AHEAD COMMITTEE ON
BEHALF OF CITIZENS FROM LOS
ANGELES WILDLIFE ALSO KNOWN AS
THE CLOCK IN STRONG SUPPORT.
LINE NUMBER FIFTY SIX LINE FIVE
SIX YOU MAY GO AHEAD MY NAME IS
WITHIN GOVERNMENT BOARD MEMBER
AND CONSERVATION COMMITTEE
CHAIR FOR GOLDEN GATE AUDUBON
SOCIETY AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
MY NUMBER SIXTEEN LINE ONE SIX
YOU MAY GO AHEAD. DR LORETTA
MAYER WOMEN IN SCIENCE DOING
OUTREACH AND MENTORING GENERAL
PARTNER I SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT. MY
NUMBER THIRTY FOUR LINE THREE
FOUR YOU MAY GO AHEAD. DR TONY
BARNES WITH THE FIX UNDER ASIAN
I'M A VETERINARIAN IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT. MY NUMBER THIRTY THREE
LINE THREE THREE YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. TEN THIRTY THREE WE DO
HAVE THE LINE OPEN FOR YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK. OKAY NOT
GETTING A RESPONSE WILL GO TO
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY SEVEN LINE ONE EATEN.
YET YEAH. I THINK IT'S A GOOD
IDEA. I DON'T KNOW YOUR MIND IS
PLENTY THAT THE LINE OPEN FOR
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK. THANK
HI YOUR LINE IS OPEN MA'AM YOU
CAN GO AHEAD AND SPEAK. MARYANN
DAVIS SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
AUDUBON SOCIETY EXECUTIVE BOARD
ON BEHALF OF THE TWO THOUSAND
MEMBERS STRONGLY IN SUPPORT. MY
NUMBER EIGHTY TWO NINE EIGHT
TWO YOU MAY GO AHEAD. ROBERT
HEARD FOR SANTA CLARA VALLEY
AUDUBON SOCIETY IN SUPPORT OF
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT TO
PROGRAM THE UNINTENDED ADVERSE
IMPACT ON NON TARGET WILDLIFE
SPECIES THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
SIX NINE SIX YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE SIX WE
HAVE THE LINE OPEN FOR YOU.
BONTA TOMLINSON REPRESENTING
THE THIRTY SEVEN HUNDRED
CALIFORNIA MEMBERS OF THE
PROJECT K. O. D. AND WE ARE ALL
IN SUPPORT. MY NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE LINE
ONE TWO FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI NATALIE NOT GOING TO HAPPEN
IT'S NOT GONNA REGIONAL OPEN
SPACE DISTRICT AND BEFORE. I
NUMBER TWENTY SIX LINE TWO SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWENTY SIX WE
HAVE THE LINE OPEN FOR YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK. THIS IS LISA
LEVIN FAMILY IN DEFENSE OF
ANIMALS AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT.
AB ONE SEVEN EIGHT EIGHT. THE
LINE NUMBER SEVENTY ONE LINE
SEVEN ONE YOU MAY GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS BEN CAN BE HIGH
ENOUGH TO PORT EIGHTY SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT. MY NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SIX LINE ONE
EIGHT SIX YOU MAY GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS RACHEL HEYMAN I AM A
CERTIFIED WILDLIFE TRACKER AND
A VOLUNTEER WITH THE MOUNTAIN
LION FOUNDATION. I'M FROM SANTA
BARBARA AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT. BY NUMBER FORTY TWO LINE
FOUR TWO YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
SENATOR GLAZERS WITH THE
NATIONAL PARKS CONSERVATION
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. I
NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN LINE TWO
SEVEN YOU MAY GO AHEAD ELAINE
LIVE CITY COUNCIL AND- WHICH
PULLED BACK AND ROBUST SUPPORT
OF AB. ONE SEVEN EIGHT EIGHT.
LINE NUMBER ELEVEN LINE AT ONE
ONE YOU MAY GO AHEAD. WE'RE NAY
ROBSON I AM A BURGER AND
PASSIONATE SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT. I
NUMBER FIFTY EIGHT LINE FIVE
EACH YOU MAY GO AHEAD. HI
CYNTHIA CUP HOLLYWOOD HILLS
ANIMAL LOVER IN SUPPORT OF.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT. MY
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
TWO LINE ONE TWO TWO YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. TRICIA CALL MIGHT
VENTURA COUNTY I'M IN. SUPPORT
OF AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY. MY
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY
TWO LINE TWO FOUR TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MICHELLE MCKENZIE FROM
MENLO PARK WILDLIFE LOVER IN
STRONG SUPPORT. YEAH MY NUMBER
NINETY FOUR LINE AT NINE FOUR
YOU MAY GO AHEAD. HOLD ON
BEHALF OF THE MOUNTAIN LAND
FOUNDATION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT.
NUMBER SEVENTY THREE NINE SEVEN
THREE YOU MAY GO AHEAD. KARAKUL
COLIN MY CONCERN SINCE THEN AND
THE WILDLIFE ADVOCATE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT. LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND FORTY FIVE LINE TWO FOUR
FIVE YOU MAY GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING SYLVIA POLICE SHOT ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES AND THE CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
STREAMLINED TWO ZERO THREE YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS ROSE
GROWING FROM A RESIDENT OF
CUPERTINO AND SENATOR DEAL
DISTRICT FIFTEEN AND I'M
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT. WELL MY
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND NINE
NINE ONE ZERO NINE YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS A LEASE
BUCKLEY WEBER ON THE MAYOR OF
THE CITY OF AGORA HILLS AND I'M
CALLING FROM MY CELL IN SUPPORT
OF AB. SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT.
MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
THREE NINE ONE SIX THREE YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. HIGHLINE ONE
SIXTY THREE WE HAVE THE LINE
OPEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK. OKAY
WE'LL MOVE ON- THE NEXT PERSON
IS LINE AT ONE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY FOUR NINE ONE SIX FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. KAREENA DOING
GO FOR THEY KEEP THER
CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT AND
EIGHTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
THANK YOU ARE. MY NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR LINE
ONE THREE FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THIS IS JENNIFER
FEARING EXPRESSING STRONG
SUPPORT FOR AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT ON BEHALF OF THE CENTER
FOR FOOD SAFETY CALIFORNIANS
FOR PESTICIDE REFORM THE
MOUNTAIN LION FOUNDATION SAN
DIEGO HUMANE SOCIETY AND THE
SAN FRANCISCO SPCA. THANK YOU.
I NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT NINE TWO
EIGHT YOU MAY GO AHEAD. BOB
ROBINSON WHICH ARE YOUR
INTUITION ONLINE ON BEHALF OF
THE HUMANE SOCIETY OF THE
UNITED STATES IN SUPPORT. WHY
NUMBER SIXTY TWO LINE SIX TWO
YOU MAY GO AHEAD. TWO RIVERS A
FORMER MAYOR DAVIS CALIFORNIA
SPEAKING FOR MYSELF IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE JOIN THE COALITION.
ONE A NUMBER FORTY NINE LINE
FOUR NINE YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS JANET COVERS
THAT REPRESENTING PROJECT HOW
UT AND RAPTORS ARE THE SOLUTION
IN SUPPORT OF AB. SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT. Y. NUMBER THIRTY
FIVE LINE THREE FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS CHARLOTTE
KAROSA AND I AS WELL AND THEN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU. NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWO LINE
TWO SIX TWO YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
PAN AM PROSSIMI GOLDEN GATE
RAPTOR OBSERVATORY VOLUNTEER I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL. LINE
NUMBER NINETY ONE LINE AT NINE
OF ONE YOU MAY GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME BILLION AGUILAR
FROM LOS ANGELES COUNTY
INTERMENT STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY FOUR LINE TWO SIX FOUR
YOU MAY GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
DONNA WESTLANDS RETIRED
VETERINARIAN- CHIPPING IN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
WILDLIFE AND- CALIFORNIANS
COMPANION ANIMAL CONTROL
REPORTER AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND NINETY
SIX LINE ONE NINE SIX YOU MAY
GO AHEAD. PLAINGALLON
REPRESENTING PACIFIC WILDLIFE
CARE ON SOME OF THE BEST BOOK
COUNTY AND WEARING STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB. SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN LINE ONE
ONE EACH YOU MAY GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS THOMAS AYE
CORN IN ORANGE COUNTY
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. AND MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND NINETY SEVEN LINE ONE NINE
SEVEN YOU MAY GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS LEE DOUGLAS I AM
RESEARCH CONTRACTOR OR DO YOU
STAY REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT AND
I SUPPORT IT ONE SEVENTY EIGHT
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER SIXTY FIVE
LINE SIX FIVE YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
JAMIE CARINO CALLING ON BEHALF
OF HUMBOLDT RAPTORS ARTIST
LUCIAN AND STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER FORTY SIX LINE
FOR SIX YOU MAY GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS JEANNIE SAM A MEMBER OF
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY AND ORDERS
FOR THE RAPTORS AGAINST OURS
THE SOLUTION AND I TO COURT AB
ONE SEVEN EIGHT EIGHT. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY EIGHT LINE TO FIGHT EACH
YOU MAY GO AHEAD. ONE OF THE
OKAY- DEFINITELY NOT AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE FOUR NINE TWO
FIFTY WE HAVE TO LINE OPEN FOR
YOU IF YOU WISH TO REACH. HELLO
MY NAME IS ANASTASIA HOBBIT IN
THE NATURAL HISTORY DOESN'T END
MOUNT DIABLO STATE PARK AND I
AM IN STRONG SUPPORT. OF
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE NINE TWO
SIX FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR
A LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT
CALIFORNIA NINE STRONG SUPPORT
OF SEVENTEEN NINETY EIGHT THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY NINE NINE TWO SIX NINE
YOU MAY GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
PAULINE WRITES AND I'M CALLING
TO GET MY STRONG SUPPORT FOR AB.
ONE SEVEN EIGHT EIGHT. MY
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FOUR NINE TWO SEVEN FOUR YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. YES HELLO
CRISTINA CURRENTS FOR ANIMAL
DEFENDERS INTERNATIONAL ARE
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIA
SUPPORTERS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB. SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT. WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE TWO SEVEN NINE. THIS
IS JERRY HANS FOR FRIENDS OF
GRIFFITH PARK IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT. HELLO
AND THANK YOU WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
SEVEN NINE TWO SEVEN SEVEN YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. YOU ALL SOLD
UNFORTUNATELY. STRONG SUPPORT
FOR AB. SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT.
WHY NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND.
SIXTY SIX NINE TWO SIX SIX YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS VAL
NERIO- WITH BERKELEY'S- RAPTORS
ARE THE SOLUTION I'M INSTALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF BILL
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. YEAH THANK YOU LINE NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
ELAINE TWO TWO FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS RANDY BY
LISTING CALIPARI CALIFORNIA
VOLUNTEER PROJECT. AND QUAKER
CREEK CALABASAS IN CONCORD AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. WHY NUMBER TWENTY THREE
LINE TWO THREE YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
THIS IS KEREN CASE HERE WITH ME
OUT THE OTHER LOW AUDUBON
SOCIETY IN CONTRA COSTA COUNTY.
I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT. MY
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FOUR LINE TWO EIGHT FOUR YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS NOT LEYVA LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS MANAGER FOR THE CITY OF
THOUSAND OAKS THE CITY IS
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. HE
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN AND AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SHOW SUPPORT OF AB ONE
SEVEN E. YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. NUMBER THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE THREE
THREE. ONE THIRTY THREE WE HAVE
THE LINE OPEN FOR YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK. OKAY REMOVING
UNDERLINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY ONE POINT SEVEN ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
SANDRA HOLLOWAY I'M A NATIVE
CALIFORNIAN AND I SUPPORT
EIGHTY ONE SEVEN EIGHT EIGHT.
THANK YOU. FINE TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY SEVEN ONE TWO FOUR SEVEN
YOU MAY GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS JULIET LAMONT I AM THE
FORMER CHAIR OF THE BAY CHAPTER
OF THE SIERRA CLUB SPEAKING FOR
MYSELF BUT ALSO AN AVID MEMBER
OF RAPTORS ARTICULATION IN THE
BERKELEY AREA I AM IN. FULL
SUPPORT OF AB ONE SEVEN EIGHT
EIGHT. M. LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE LINE TWO
FOUR NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS MONEY GOOD THEN WITH
WILDLIFE CREE HAVE BEEN
RELEASED RAPTOR CENTER IN PENN
VALLEY CALIFORNIA AND I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT. MY NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THREE LINE
TWO SEVEN THREE YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. THE NEW SOME CALLING ON
BEHALF OF MYSELF I AM IN
COMPLETE SUPPORT OF AB. ONE
SEVEN EIGHT EIGHT. MY NUMBER
FORTY FIVE LINE FOUR FIVE YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. THANK YOU LINE
FORTY FIVE WE HAVE THE LINE
OPEN FOR YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK. UNDER MY NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY NINE TWO
EIGHT ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS KELLY THOMPSON I'M A
VOLUNTEER PROJECT PRIORITY AND
I'M STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT. FINE WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE Q. EIGHT Q. HI MY NAME IS
JOHN TARANTINO. AND I AM A
VOLUNTEER PROJECT CARRY. ON THE
SUPPORTER AND I SUPPORT AB. ONE
SEVENTY EIGHTY EIGHT. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTEEN LINE TWO ONE THREE YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. THIS IS KEITH
WILSON BOARD MEMBER OF SAN
DIEGO CANYON LANDS IN STRONG
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF THE
ORGANIZATION OF AB. ONE SEVEN
EIGHT EIGHT. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN- TO SHOW SUPPORT OF
AB ONE SEVEN EIGHT EIGHT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN IF ZERO
AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT OF AB ONE
SEVEN EIGHT EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. FOR GOING BACK
TO LINE NUMBER THIRTY THREE-
PLEASE GO AHEAD THE LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS SAM I AM
CALLING IN FOR QUICKLY YEAH.
AND MY NUMBER FORTY FIVE LINE
FOUR FIVE YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE FORTY FIVE
WE HAVE THE LINE OPEN FOR YOU.
NINE FORTY FIVE IF YOU WANT TO
CHECK YOUR MUTE BUTTON WE DO
HAVE THE LINE OPEN. WE'RE NOT
GETTING A RESPONSE ON THAT
LINE- I HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE FOR SUPPORT OF AB ONE
SEVEN EIGHT EIGHT. THANK YOU
MADAM MODERATE IN ME I HAVE-
PARDON ME I'M I DO APOLOGIZE I
DO I DO HAVE SEVERAL THAT HAVE
QUEUED UP WE HAVE TO THAT HAVE
QUEUED UP. I HAVE LINE NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE TWO THREE
ONE. HELLO MY NAME. NEO
CANDYLAND AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. MY NUMBER FORTY FIVE
ONE FOUR FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
STEVE TYLER ON BEHALF OF
RAPTORS OF THE SOLUTION AND
PROJECT COMMUNITY FULLY SUPPORT
AB ONE SEVEN EIGHT EIGHT. AND
AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO
SHOW SUPPORT OF AB ONE SEVEN
EIGHT EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND NINETY NINE TWO
NINE ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. MARY
HERNANDEZ- THE EXECUTIVE BOARD
FOR PCO FEE AND- BUSINESS OWNER
MASON CITY HUMILIATION OF SANTA
MARIA. I OPPOSE THIS BILL. WE
WERE STILL ON SUPPORT OF AB.
ONE SEVEN EIGHT EIGHT. FIVE I'M
NOT SURE HOW I GOT INTO THE
SUPPORT BUT I OPPOSE THAT. OKAY
WE HAVE ONE MORE PERSON IN THE
QUEUE IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT.
BEEN A MAINLINE NUMBER IT'LL BE
JUST A MOMENT. AND LINE NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE TWO NINE
SEVEN ONE ZERO. EIGHT ONE ZERO.
TWO NINETY. TWO NINETY SEVEN WE
HAVE THE LINE OPEN FOR YOU YOU
DON'T NEED TO PRESS ANY BUTTONS
ON THE PHONE OKAY AT THIS IS
RANDALL. AND OUR STRONG
SUPPORTER WILDLIFE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU I WOULD HAVE WON
NUMBER SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
SIX. NINE SIX WE HAVE THE LINE
OPEN FOR YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK. DEBBIE LARELL IN SUPPORT
OF AB. SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT.
HAVE LINE NUMBER THREE HUNDRED
LINE THREE ZERO ZERO YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS CHRISTINE
SANBORN I'M A VOLUNTEER WITH
THE OJAI RAPTOR CENTER AND I AM
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. I HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE FOR SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT YOU MAY
CONTINUE. THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR WILL NOW GO TO
OPPOSITION AND I SEE NO WHEN ME
AND ROOM FORTY TWO THREE
STEPPING UP. NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. OZ SO IF YOU'LL PLEASE
PROMPTLY INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT MADAME
MODERATOR. IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB ONE
SEVEN E. YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
IF ZERO. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE
POINT TWO FIVE FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES THERE IN MAINSTREAM
WORK ON BEHALF OF CORPORATE
CONTROL IN OPPOSITION OF.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT. OKAY I
HAVE FILED MY NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD LINE TWO SIX SEVEN.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN CALLING
ON BEHALF RISE RESPONSIBLE
INDUSTRY CRISTINA WILL
EMPOWERMENT AND WESTERN PLANT
HEALTH ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. AND I
HAVE LINE NUMBER SIXTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE SIX THREE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN MY
NAME IS DAVE HENDRIX I
REPRESENT WHAT PASSED FOR THE
PAST CONTROL OPERATORS OF
CALIFORNIANS SAN DIEGO.
PROPOSED AB. SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT. I HAVE LINE NUMBER
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE AGO
HEADLINE NINETY. MY NAME'S DEAN
RILEY I'M I'M WITH THE BEST
CONTROL OPERATORS CALIFORNIA
AND IN THE INTEREST OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AYE OPPOSED AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT. I HAVE LINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE ONE
THREE THREE. GERAKAN ADDRESS
WITHIN- RANCHO CORDOVA
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION OF AB
SEVENTEEN EDT. OKAY I HAVE LINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FIVE LINE ONE SEVEN FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TOM GRACEN PRESIDENT
OF THE PEST CONTROL OPERATORS
OF CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT. I HAVE LINE NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY NINE ONE SIX
ZERO YOU MAY GO AHEAD. WE HAD
LINE ONE SIX ZERO WE HAVE THE
LINE OPEN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK. GOOD LUCK WE'RE GOING
BEHALF OF PEST CONTROL
OPERATORS OF CALIFORNIA. I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AB.
ONE SEVEN EIGHT EIGHT. CAN'T
FIND. YEAH I. AND WE HAVE Y.
NUMBERED TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE TWO
SIX THREE. DAVID HARMON WHICH
WHICH HAS CONTROL SOCIAL SORT
OF ON ENTOMOLOGISTS A MEMBER OF
PEST CONTROL OPERATORS
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE BILL.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT. AND MY
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY
EIGHT LINE ONE FOR EACH PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS CHRIS
FROM ELLIS BIOLOGIST AND PEST
CONTROL INDUSTRY LIVING IN LA
CRESCENTA CALIFORNIA. IN
INTEREST THE PUBLIC HEALTH I
STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B. SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD LINE ONE EEK. HELLO THIS
IS RUSSELL PHILLIPS WITH CLARK
PEST CONTROL AND BCLC AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE BILL AB. ONE
SEVEN EIGHT EIGHT. WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE TWO
THREE FIVE. LOCAL TEAM
PRESIDENT OF EL DORADO COUNTY I
REPRESENT CORTES CONTROL PEST
CONTROL OPERATORS CALIFORNIA
AND THE NATIONAL MANAGEMENT
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
OPPOSED THAT L. A. B.
SEVENTEEN. I'M INTERESTED
PUBLIC HEALTH. AND LINE NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY THREE
LINE TWO FIVE THREE PLEASE GO
AGAIN. DAVID OXLEY WITH OXLEY
BEST CONTROL A BIGGER SO
CALIFORNIA AND A MEMBER OF THE
PEST CONTROL OPERATORS IN
CALIFORNIA. AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE LAWSUIT TOOLS TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC HEALTH
MINISTRY OF THE DISEASE. WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY FIVE HIS GO AHEAD
LINE TWO SEVEN FIVE. MY NAME IS
HEATHER GARCIA ON BEHALF OF
CLARK PEST CONTROL PEST CONTROL
OPERATORS TO CALIFORNIA AND
NATIONAL PEST MANAGEMENT
ASSOCIATION IN THE INTEREST OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION UP AB ONE SEVEN
EIGHT EIGHT. MY NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND TO PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE TWO ZERO TWO. CHUCK SMITH
WESSON REGIONAL MANAGER AND
BOARD CERTIFIED ENTOMOLOGIST
WITH BELL LABORATORIES AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB SEVENTEEN
NINETY EIGHT. I NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD NINE TWO FIVE FOUR. MY
NAME IS SEAN GLOVER WITH THE-
PROTECT YOUR NUTS I'M AN
ASSOCIATE CERTIFIED
ENTOMOLOGIST OF PCO THE BAND
AND PMA. WE PROVIDES A TO
PROTECTION- IN OUR COMPANY AND
THIS TOOL THIS AB SEVENTY EIGHT
EIGHT WITH TECH. TOOLS AWAY
FROM. PROTECTING THE FOOD
SUPPLY OPPOSE. AND MY NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR LINE
TWO FOUR FOUR YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS VINCE FROM MAYO I
SUPPORT THE CALIFORNIA PEST
CONTROL ASSOCIATION. I'M A
LOVER OF HUMAN BEINGS AND
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SUPPORT. TO
PROTECT. NON TARGET SPECIES I
STRONGLY OPPOSE BILL AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT. GETTING
CREATIVE LINE NUMBER NINETY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE NUMBER
NINE SIX. MY NAME IS JACKIE
CLARK WITH WHAT HAD CONTROL OF
THE BILL. MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND. FIFTY NINE ONE FIVE ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWENTY CHARLES
CAMARA CARPET CONTROL AND I
STRONG OPPOSED HE. ONE SEVENTY.
HAVE LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE TWO EIGHT NINE. THIS IS
ROBERT KEEP BAY BEST SOLUTION
SAN JOSE NUMBER OF BCLC I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB ONE SEVEN
EIGHT EIGHT. IN MY NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE NINE
ONE TWO NINE YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
BALLERINA FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
OPPOSITION. TO EIGHT HUNDRED
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE.
YEAH WHY NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE TWO FOUR EIGHT. OKAY LET
ME KNOW. MY NUMBER TWO HUNDRED
AND FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I DON'T. I GETTING RESPONSE
ONLINE TWO FOUR EIGHT WE'LL GO
AHEAD TWO LINE NUMBER. TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY LINE TWO SIX
ZERO. YES THIS IS TRY MEDICAL
ASSOCIATE CERTIFIED
ENTOMOLOGIST WITH A QUICK PRESS
CONTROL PEST CONTROL OPERATORS
THE CALIFORNIA AND NATIONAL
PEST MANAGEMENT ASSOCIATION. IN
THE INTEREST OF PUBLIC HEALTH I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER TWENTY TWO LINE TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ROBERT BAKER
CLARK PEST CONTROL AND PEST
CONTROL OPERATORS CALIFORNIA
AND THE NATIONAL PEST
MANAGEMENT ASSOCIATION AND IN
THE INTEREST OF PUBLIC HEALTH I
AM STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL. YOU HAVE MY NUMBER THREE
ZERO TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD THREE
OH TWO. CAPEN CARRYING ON A
RESIDENT OF SAN DIEGO AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. AND I HAVE
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE ONE ONE SEVEN FIVE
MEANWHILE I HAD. IS THAT
POSSIBLE. ONE SEVENTY FIVE WE
HAVE THE LINE OPEN FOR YOU IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK. YEAH. NOT
GETTING A RESPONSE ARE MOVING
ON WITH THE DISCONNECTED WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER THREE HUNDRED
AND TEN LINE THREE ONE ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
KAREN BRANCH I'M A RESIDENTIAL
CARE OF CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE BILL AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. FOR ALL. HE ONE MOMENT.
AND WE HAVE LINE NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE TWO SEVEN
EIGHT. GOOD MORNING JAMIE WILL
LET US CONTROL REPRESENTED
THREE HUNDRED EMPLOYEES PASS
CONTROL. CAN WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
BILL. SEVENTEEN EIGHTY. THANK
YOU OUR NEXT- FOR OPPOSITION
ONE MOMENT HERE WE ARE GOING TO
LIE NUMBER THREE ZERO NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE THREE ZERO
NINE. HELLO MY NAME IS BEVERLY
TALL THE CONSUMER. I SUPPORT A.
B. SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT- VERY
STRONGLY. HELLO OKAY THANK YOU
ARE WE GOING NEXT- TO THE LINE
OF THREE ONE ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD ONLINE THREE ELEVEN. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS KATHY LANCE
REPRESENTING ANIMAL PEST
MANAGEMENT SERVICES IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY ATTACHED TO
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. YOU HAVE MY NUMBER THREE
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN YES GO
AHEAD NINE THREE ONE FOUR.
HELLO MY NAME IS ALBERT TO BARS
FROM CLARK PEST CONTROL AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B. SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ST ZERO. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVEN NINE THREE ZERO SEVEN YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. THIS IS MERRY
HERNANDEZ RESIDENT SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY AND OWNER OF
MISSION CITY GIVE ME GAUGE THAT
SANTA MARIA AND A MEMBER OF THE
EXECUTIVE BOARD OF THE PCMC I
STRONGLY OPPOSE BILL SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT. AND WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER TWO HUNDRED AND NINETY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE TWO
NINE NINE. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS NICOLE COMMUNITY REPRESENT
THE HOUSEHOLD AND COMMERCIAL
PRODUCTS AT THE STATION AND WE
OPPOSE EIGHTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTY.
I HAVE MY NUMBER THREE HUNDRED
AND FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE THREE ONE FIVE. YES MY
NAME IS SYLVIA CAN YOUR BOARD
CERTIFIED ENTOMOLOGIST AND
IRVINE RESIDENT AND I OPPOSE AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU I HAVE A ONE MORE PERSON IN
THE QUEUE WERE GIVING THEM A
LINE NUMBER JUST A MOMENT. NINE
ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE ONE SIX
EIGHT. YEAH THIS IS- JOE GATTO
WITH CLARK PEST CONTROL IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL. NINE
NINE. GOOD MORNING. JUST A
MOMENT WHILE WE GIVE THEM THEIR
LINE NUMBER. THE LINE NUMBER
THREE NINETEEN THANK YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. HI A CHANCE CAL ROCKLIN
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER THREE
EIGHTEEN GO AHEAD PLEASE. THIS
GENERATING OF BROWN'S WILDLIFE
REHABILITATION IN THE LEAD AND
CAN BARELY CALIFORNIA. TIMELY
SUPPORT. WHERE. LINE NUMBER
THREE SIXTEEN GO AHEAD. PATRICK
LUNCH WITH BELL LABORATORIES
ASSOCIATE CERTIFIED
ENTOMOLOGIST AND MDMA PUBLIC
POLICY COMMITTEE. STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THE BILL IN THE
INTEREST OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
THE SAFETY OF ALL CALIFORNIANS.
OUR ONLY NUMBER THREE TWENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS STATE THE COURT DOESN'T
ALL NATIONAL PEST MANAGEMENT
ASSOCIATION THAT'S THE POOL
OPERATORS IN CALIFORNIA. IN THE
INTEREST OF PUBLIC HEALTH I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. WITH
NO FOR THE LINES THIS TIME.
THANK YOU WOULD YOU A PLEASE
CHECK THE LINES AND MAKE SURE
ALL WITNESSES HAVE HAD A CHANCE
TO OUR STATE THEIR POSITION.
THERE SEEM TO BE SOME CONFUSION
THE MORE LINE. ALL MY NUMBER TO
FORTY EIGHT IS NOW OPEN. PINE
TO FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND I'M
NOT GETTING A RESPONSE FROM
THAT LINE OKAY. ALL LINE THREE
OH ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH
I AM MAUREEN COLD CAL AND I AM
IN SUPPORT OF THIS NOW. WE'RE
STILL REQUIRED ONE. NINE ONE
SEVENTY ONE EUROPEN. THANK YOU
DOMINICK LORI ABOUT HALF THE
POSTAL OPERATOR'S CALIFORNIA IN
THE INTEREST OF PUBLIC UP TO
SIXTY HI TO YOU ON BEHALF OF
CONSPIRACY. SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
THANK YOU. BY NUMBER TWO FORTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
TWO FORTY EIGHT OR NINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I APOLOGIZE
YOU'RE NOT RECEIVING A RESPONSE
FROM THAT LINE. OKAY I GOT IT
THANK YOU. WELL MIND TO TWELVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CHRIS
RIORDAN BUT CONTROL UPPERS THE
CALIFORNIA WE OPPOSE AB.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT. NINE TO
FORTY EIGHT IS NOW OPEN AGAIN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ASHLEY FREEMAN
PUBLIC HEALTH BIOLOGIST OPPOSES
SO. NO FOR THE LINE TO THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR
I'M- THE ARE NONE OF WHICH
CHECK THE LINE I THINK EVERYONE
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY SO WE WILL
MOVE TO THE TO. OUR DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. THANK YOU THE
DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION ESTIMATES A
REDUCTION OF ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN ANNUAL
REVENUES A TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
PESTICIDE REGULATION FUND. DUE
TO A REDUCTION IN MIDDLESEX
MEANT COLLECTIONS AS A RESULT
OF THIS BILL. ADDITIONALLY THE
DEPARTMENT ESTIMATES A
PROPORTIONAL REDUCTION TO THE
ALLOCATION TO THE COUNTY
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONERS AS
WELL AS THE DEPARTMENT FOOD
AGRICULTURE. WHICH ALSO
RECEIVED FUNDING FROM THIS
ASSESSMENT. THANK YOU
DEPARTMENT ADDITIONALLY NOTES
THE BILL MAY RESULT IN UNKNOWN
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
DIRECTOR'S DETERMINATION OF AN
EMERGENCY USE OF SECOND
GENERATION. ANTICOAGULANT
RODENTICIDES AS WELL AS ANY
POTENTIAL APPEALS OF THE
DIRECTOR'S DECISION TO APPROVE
OR DENY EMERGENCY USE REQUEST.
LASTLY THE BILL MAY IMPOSE
ADDITIONAL DUTIES ON COUNTY
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONERS.
WHICH COULD BE TURNED TO THE
STATE REIMBURSABLE MANDATE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS YOU KNOW
HANDS UP. ALSO WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT WILL BE MOVED TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE FOR THE NEXT ITEM
ON OUR AGENDA IS AB NINETEEN
FORTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH. IT IS ALSO A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE AND ON THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAS WAY
PRESENTATION SO ME RIGHT INTO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY AND I SEE NO
ON I DO SEE SOMEONE HERE. AND
NOW FORTY TWO OH THREE. PLEASE
REFER LIMON MICRON VENTURE
WOMAN MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MARK SMITH ON BEHALF OF CCA
CALIFORNIA COASTAL CONSERVATION
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA SPONSORS
OF THE MEASURE IN FULL SUPPORT
TODAY WE DO WANT TO REMIND THE
COMMITTEE THAT THERE IS A
BUDGET ALLOCATION THAT WAS
APPROVED THIS YEAR BY THE
LEGISLATURE SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR THAT IS INVESTING AN
ADDITIONAL HALF MILLION DOLLARS
INTO THIS PROGRAM. THE
STATUTORY FIX GOES ALONG WITH
THAT INVESTMENT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE DECIDED TO MAKE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
ANYWAY IN ROOM ONE TWELVE I SEE
NO. ONE KNOCKING UP THERE SO
MADAM MODERATOR IF YOU PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF AB.
NINETEEN FORTY NINE. IF YOU
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB ONE NINE FOUR NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO TO RECEIVE A
LINE NUMBER. ONE MOMENT THE WAY
PER LINE NUMBER.
THREE TWENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN I AM I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT THE BAND
THAT PASSED THE SIGN. I LIVE IN
PALM SPRINGS AND I'VE SEEN HE
HORRIBLE EFFECTS IT HAS ON
WILDLIFE SO I URGE YOU TO
PLEASE SUPPORT THE BILL. WE ARE
ON AB NINETEEN FORTY NINE.
PHOTOS AND SUPPORT MATAMATA
READER PLEASE OPEN THEIR LINES.
OKAY NINE ONE OH FOUR IS NOW
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS BILAL MARNIE I'M A CCA
BOARD MEMBER IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE SUPPORT AB.
NINETEEN FORTY NINE. IF THERE
ARE OTHERS OF A LIKE TO SUPPORT.
A. B. NINETEEN FORTY NINE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. THE REFERENCE NUMBER WE
HAVE NO MORE LINES AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVE TO ARE
THOSE IN OPPOSITION- FOR ANY
WITNESSES PRESENT HERE IN FORTY
TWO OH THREE NINE NINE E. IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE I SEE NONE. OF
MATAMATA READER IF YOU'LL
PLEASE PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB. NINETEEN
FORTY NINE. IF YOU WISH TO FIND
OUT THE VERSION OF AB NINETEEN
FORTY NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THE.
CURRENTLY WE HAVE NO LINES AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU THERE NOW
WE WILL GO TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. HE THEN SHARED A WHERE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE.
BECAUSE WE IT IS BEING TO ADD
OR MODIFY ANY PROGRAMMATIC
REQUIREMENTS ON THE DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE UNTIL IT
SERVICE BASED BUDGET REVIEW IS
COMPLETE. OF PRELIMINARY
RESULTS OF IDENTIFIED GAPS IN
SPECIFIED LEVELS OF SERVICE AND
THEREFORE WE FEEL IT'S NOT
PRUDENT TO ADD ADDITIONAL
UNFUNDED STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS
THAT MAY EXACERBATE THESE
IDENTIFIED GAPS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
I SEE NO HANDS UP. THEN WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB NINETEEN FORTY
NINE IS MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE
FILE. MOVING ON THE NEXT ITEM
ON OUR AGENDA IS AB NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAY. IT IS  SPENCE CANDIDATE
AND THE AUTHOR HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION SO MOVE RIGHT INTO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY AT ALL FOR
THOSE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. BY C. NINE IN THIS
ROOM ON NINE AND NOW ROOM ONE
TWELVE. AMANDA MARGARITA IF
YOU'LL PLEASE PROMPTLY
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR. IF YOU TO TESTIFY
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE MOMENT
WAY FOR LINE. THIS. HE. C.
MOBILE. DEAD LINE HAD DROPPED.
CURRENTLY WE HAVE NO OTHER
LINES AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
THEN WE WILL MOVE TO THE
OPPOSITION I DO NOT SEE ANYONE
IN THIS ROOM FOR OUR POSITION
ON YOUR IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
SEOUL MATAMATA READER PLEASE
PROMPTLY INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. OF AB.
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR. IT'S
POINT IN OPPOSITION OF AB.
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
CURRENTLY WE HAVE NO LINES AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU THEN WE
WILL MOVE TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO HAVE A FILE. THANK
YOU THE CALIFORNIA HORSE RACING
BOARD ESTIMATES THE BILL WILL
RESULT IN ADDITIONAL REVENUE OF
APPROXIMATELY ONE MILLION TO
ONE POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY TO THE HORSE AND
JOCKEY SAFETY WELFARE ACCOUNT.
WE WOULD KNOW THAT THIS WILL
REDIRECT- THESE REVENUES THAT
ARE CURRENTLY RECEIVED FROM
LICENSE FEES PENALTIES AND
FINES OTHER CURRENTLY BEING
DEPOSITED INTO THE GENERAL FUND.
THESE ADDITIONAL OF THESE
FRIENDS BECAUSE INITIALLY
APPROPRIATED AND REDIRECTED
WITHOUT REGARD TO FISCAL YEAR
RELEGATION. TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF AGRICULTURE. TO THE BOARD OF
FOR OF COURSE WELFARE AND
SAFETY MEASURES THANK YOU YOU
MEMBERS I SEE NO HANDS UP THEN
WE WILL. MOVE FROM AB NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR TO THE SUSPENSE
FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION. THE
NEXT ITEM ON OUR AGENDA IS AB
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT FIVE SIMPLY
MEMBER OF YEAR CURRY WHICH IS
ALSO A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE AND
THEY HAVE WAIVED PRESENTATIONS
SO WE WILL MOVE RIGHT TO THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY. ARE FOR THOSE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
ON NINE HERE IN THIS ROOM NINE
NINE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE SO
MATAMATA MODERATOR. PLEASE
PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OF AB TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT. IF
YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. CURRENTLY WE HAVE NO
LINES AT THIS TIME. I THANK YOU
THEN WE WILL MOVE TO OPPOSITION
NOT ANYONE WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO AB. TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT. IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
HAVE NO LINES AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU I MISSED LOOKING IN
THIS ROOM AND IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE FOR EITHER SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION I DIDN'T NOTICE ANY
SO. WE WILL GO NOW TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HI IF YOU
HAVE A FILE. THANK YOU WE KNOW
THIS BILL WILL INCREASE STATE
WORKLOAD HAS RESULTED IN
MEDIATING ACCESSIBILITY ISSUES
FOR LARGE VOLUMES OF MATERIAL
OF PRIOR TO BEING MADE
AVAILABLE ONLINE WHAT THE
PRECISE NUMBER OF AND SHE'S
MEETING THE DEFINITION OF STATE
BODY. IS UNKNOWN WE ASSUME
UNDER THE STATEWIDE COST OF
THIS BILL COULD BE INDIA
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MEMBERS ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS I SEE NO
HANDS UP THEN WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT IS OVED
TO THE SUSPENSE FILE NEXON ARE-
MAGENTA AB TWENTY FIFTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF CALM LONGER
ON IMAGE EMERGENCY SERVICES IT
IS THE SEVENTH CANDIDATE HANDED
IT OFF PRESENTATION HAS BEEN
WEIGHED ARE HIS OR ANYONE HERE
IN OH I'M SORRY I DIDN'T LOOK
UP GO AHEAD YOU DID NOT WAY
PRESENTATION SO PLEASE PROCEED
SORRY THANK YOU NO WORDS
APOLOGIES I THINK SENATOR
BRADFORD WAS TRYING TO WAVE ME
BY TALKING TO ME RIGHT NOW.
APOLOGIES FOR THAT AND GOOD
MORNING AND MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
I KNOW THIS IS UNUSUAL I THINK
I'M THE ONLY ONE- PRESENTING
BUT I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY FIFTY FOUR WHICH WILL
CREATE A THREE YEAR PILOT
PROGRAM TO EXPAND COMMUNITY
BASED ALTERNATIVES TO POLICING
I WANNA TO STATE THAT THIS IS A
C. L. B. C. PRIORITY BILL.
EXPERTS AT COMMUNITY WORKING.
HAVE THE EX TO RESPOND TO CALLS
ABOUT MENTAL ILLNESS
HOMELESSNESS SUBSTANCE ABUSE
AND OTHER ISSUES IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AN AVERAGE OF 10% OF
U. S. LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
TOTAL BUDGETS AND A STAGGERING
21% OF TOTAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
STAFF TIME WAS SPENT RESPONDING
TO AND TRANSPORTING PERSONS
WITH MENTAL ILLNESS. FOR
EXAMPLE THE SAN FRANCISCO
POLICE DEPARTMENT. ESTIMATES
THAT UP 280% OF CALLS FOR
SERVICE IN THE CITY ARE FOR
PEOPLE AND MENTAL HEALTH
CRISES. AND THAT POLICE
OFFICERS BRING CLOSE TO FOUR
THOUSAND PEOPLE PER YEAR TO
PSYCHIATRIC FACILITIES.
SIMILARLY A TWENTY SIXTEEN
REPORT FROM THE BUDGET AND
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
ESTIMATED THAT SAN FRANCISCO
INCURRED EXPENSES OF NEARLY
TWENTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS. IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN TO ENFORCE
QUALITY OF LIFE LAWS AGAINST
HOMELESS RESIDENTS POLICE
ACCOUNTED FOR MORE THAN 90% OF
THE COST AND RESPONDED TO MORE
THAN SIXTY THOUSAND INCIDENTS.
FROM JANUARY TO NOVEMBER OF
TWENTY FIFTEEN. LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS HAVE EXPRESSED THEIR
DESIRE TO FOCUS ON LEGITIMATE
PUBLIC SAFETY EMERGENCIES.
STUDIES OF COMMUNITY BASED
RESPONSE SERVICES. INDICATE
THAT THEY ARE SIGNIFICANTLY
LESS EXPENSIVE AND PRODUCE
BETTER OUTCOMES THAN LAW
ENFORCEMENT RESPONSES TO CRISES
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS OFTEN
ARE SET UP TO ADDRESS THE ROOT
CAUSES OF ISSUES CREATING LONG
TERM SAVINGS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. IN ORDER AGAIN A
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION
CALLED THE HOOTS PROVIDES
ALTERNATIVE TO EMERGENCY
RESPONSE ITS BUDGET IS ABOUT
TWO POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY. WHEN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THE CODES TEAM ANSWERS 17% OF
THE EUGENE POLICE DEPARTMENT'S
OVERALL CALL VOLUME THE PROGRAM
SAVE THE CITY OF EUGENE AN
ESTIMATED EIGHT POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN PUBLIC
SAFETY SPENDING ANNUALLY. AGAIN
THIS BILL WOULD CREATE AND FIND
THE THREE YEAR PILOT PROGRAM IT
WOULD NOT OBLIGE FUTURE BUDGETS
TO ONGOING FUNDING AS WELL AS
MISS STATED- BY A COLLEAGUE
DURING THE LAST COMMITTEE
HEARING. COMMUNITY BASED CRISIS
RESPONSE IS A SOCIALLY AND
FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE INVESTMENT
I WANT TO ONCE AGAIN REITERATE
THAT THIS IS A C. L. B. C.
PRIORITY BILL. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS WHEN THIS
BILL COMES BEFORE YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH IN Q. ARM. ANYONE HERE
IN SUPPORT. IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OH THREE AND IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
I SEE NONE- MADAME MODERATOR I
WOULD YOU PLEASE PROP THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY FIFTY
FOUR. IF YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONLY THREE THIRTY IS NOW
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON SENATORS
ALEX TOWARDS THE STRATEGY THREE
SIXTY ON BEHALF OF HIM THAN
HERS TRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR IS NOW
OPEN. BARBARA LEADERS ON BEHALF
OF THE STEINBERG INSTITUTE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. PINE THREE
THIRTY SEVEN IS NOW OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME IS MINE AND I AM WITH
THE COUNCIL ON AMERICAN ISLAMIC
RELATIONS TECHNICAL BAY AREA
OFFICE AND I'M ALSO SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CARE CALIFORNIA
AS WELL AND WE ARE. BOTH IN
STRONG SUPPORT. ONE THREE
THIRTY IT IS NOT OPEN. GOOD
MORNING SYLVIA POLICE SHANDI
COMMITTEE OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR
ERIC GARCETTI IN. PINE ONE
NINETY TWO IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
MORNING DENNIS CLOSER METAL- ON
BEHALF OF THE MUTUAL YOU'LL
PROUD CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. NINE FOUR ZERO OR
LINE FORTY IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR A NOT TIER
NUMBERS ASSETS AMOUNTING THAT
WAY HOW PUBLIC AFFAIRS CALLING
ON BEHALF OF NARAL PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NINE ONE FORTY IS NOW OPEN.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS. OF ALL
ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA AND IMPORT. TWENTY
NINE IS NOW OPEN. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS PAUL EUROPE HAVE THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT. NINE
THREE THIRTY FOURTH. MY NAME IS
ERIC MORE SIX MINUTES I'M CALL
ON BEHALF OF PAUL COMING ALIVE
TO BOY MEDICAL AND THE
DEFAMATION LEAGUE ALL IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIFTY FOUR
THANK YOU. NINE FORTY SEVEN IS
NOW OPEN. MICHAEL MARTINEZ HERE
ON BEHALF OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWO ZERO
FIVE FOUR THANK YOU. NINE THREE
THIRTY THREE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS MICHAEL WITH
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
ONE THREE THIRTY FIVE AN OPEN.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS SAM
APPELLATE BLUEGREEN ALLIANCE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE. TWENTY
FIFTY FOUR. NINE TWO OH EIGHT
IS NOW OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
JOSEPH THERE ON BEHALF OF
TRANSGENDER GENDER VARIANT AND
INTERSECTS JUSTICE PROJECT IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY
FIFTY FOUR. ONE THREE THIRTY
SIX IS NOW OPEN. GOOD MORNING
SIGNING ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY BEHAVIOR
HEALTH AGENCY THE PORTLAND
THOUGH AN AWFUL LIKE TO
REGISTER HER SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY
EIGHT NINETY THANK YOU. NINE
THREE THIRTY NINE IS NOW OPEN.
HI THIS IS PAM BERMAN BONTA ON
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
ORGANIZATION OPENPOWER PROJECT
INJECTED FOR KILL MORE
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY FIFTY FOUR. NINE
THREE FORTY SIX IS NOW OPEN.
HELLO IS YOUR BILL GARCIA
QUALITY AND ADVOCACY MANAGER
FOR UTILIZED O'QUINN IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIFTY FOUR
THANK YOU. NINE THREE FORTY
EIGHT IS NOW OPEN. HI GOOD
MORNING THIS IS DE ANGELO MACK
ON BEHALF OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVOCATES- COSPONSORED TWENTY
FIFTY FOUR IN STRONG STRONG
STRONG SUPPORT. NINE THREE
FORTY SEVEN IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
MORNING AMANDA REVIEW THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THREE
FORTY NINE IS NOW OPEN. IT
SHOULD MORE WITH YOU W. WE ARE
CO SPONSORS OF THE BILL AND WE
ARE VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
CRISIS BACK AB TWENTY THIRTY
FOUR. THANK YOU. NINE THREE
FORTY FOUR IS NOW OPEN. CHAU
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. AND MINE ONE THIRTY
FOUR IS NOW OPEN. MORNING
JENNIFER CARRYING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFITS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY FIFTY FOUR. NO
FURTHER LINE TO THIS TIME.
THANK YOU WILL NOW GO TO OUR
OPPOSITION I SEE NO WITNESSES
HERE IN FORTY TWO OH THREE NOR
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE SOUL MADAM
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE PROP
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY BE
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION- AB. TWENTY FIFTY
FOUR. IF YOU WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO LONG
LINES AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU-
WILL NOW GO TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE DO WE HAVE A FILE.
YES THANK. WE DO NOT HAVE. WE
KNOW THAT THE BILL ON THE
RESULT IN POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT COSTS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF OFF OR FOR THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES TO
ADMINISTER THE GRANT PILOT
PROGRAM AND ISSUE GRANT FUNDING
TO ELIGIBLE GRANTEES WE WOULD
NOTE THAT THE BILL ADDRESS THE
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE FUNDING-
MAYBE DEPOSITED INTO THE NEW
FUND- AND CAN UPON
APPROPRIATION SUPPORT THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS PROGRAM.
WE WOULD NOTE THAT THE BILL
DOESN'T OTHERWISE SPECIFY
ANOTHER FUNDING SOURCE TO
SUPPORT PROGRAM COSTS- SO WE
WOULD KNOW THAT- THE BILL NAY
REQUIRE OR THE COST MAY BE
BORNE BY THE GENERAL FUND WANTS
TO SPECIFIED- YESTER
TERMINATION IS MADE. UNLESS
THEY WOULD KNOW THAT THE BILL
DOES PER. THAT IMPLEMENTATION
OF SUCH A FINDING BY CALLOW YES
THAT APPROPRIATE FUNDING HAS
BEEN MADE AVAILABLE. WE WOULD
ALSO NOTE THAT THE CRITERIA BY
WHICH KALLIO YES SHOW ME THE
FINDING- IT'S NOT CLEAR OR HOW
OR IF THE DEPARTMENT'S EXISTING
FUNDING SHOULD BE TAKEN TO
ACCOUNT TO MAKE THE
DETERMINATION. ARE OR HOW SUCH
A FINDING WILL BE INTEGRATED
INTO THE STATE'S BATCHING
PROCESS. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OUR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
OUR MEMBERS I DO NOT SEE ANY.
CONCEPT THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COME LONGER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. I JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS WHEN IT COMES
TO FOR YOU THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS. WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB TWENTY FIFTY FOUR
IS MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE FILE.
NEXT BY ON OUR AGENDA IS AB
TWENTY ONE SIXTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. DALY ON
INSURANCE MARKET ACTION PLAN
AT. THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. SO WE WILL
MOVE TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY FOR
BEGINNING WITH SUPPORT. I SEE
NONE IN THIS ROOM ARE. NINE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE SAVANNAH
MODERATOR I WOULD YOU PLEASE
PROPERTY INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB.
TWENTY ONE SIXTY SEVEN. IF YOU
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. IN THE MORNING NUMBER
TWENTY NINE IS NOW OPEN. FORTY
MANAGER MEMBERS OF THE OF THE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
THIS IS PAUL YOUR IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. NUMBER FIVE. NINE ONE
THIRTY FOUR IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING JENNIFER APPEARING ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY
ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY FARMERS IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY
SEVEN. NO FOR THE LONGEST TIME.
THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVES TO THE
OPPOSITION- C. NINE HERE IN
FORTY TWO OH THREE OR ROOM ONE
TWELVE SO MADAM MODERATOR
PLEASE PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS
ARE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY SEVEN. IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY ONE SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND ONE FORTY SEVEN IS OPEN.
MICHAEL MARTINEZ YOU'RE ON THE
OUTSIDE OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA AND
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
AB TWO ONE SIX SEVEN THANK YOU.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. IN LINE
THREE FORTY THREE IS NOW OPEN.
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG OPPOSITION.
NO FROM LAW TO THIS TIME. THANK
YOU THEN WE WILL GO TO THE-DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I DO WE
HAVE A FILE. YES THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. THIS IS A SCHOOL
THAT I WILL BE PROVIDING
INCLUDES CLASSROOM OF THIS BILL
SB TWO NINETY TWO SINCE THEY
ARE CONTINGENT ON AN ACCIDENT
AND NO PROVISION OF EITHER
SEVERAL- AND COMBINED
PROVISIONS ARE LARGELY
INTERLOCKING THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE ESTIMATES COSTS OF
APPROXIMATELY TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THREE POINT
WHERE NEARLY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO THREE POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE AND ONE
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
AND ON GOING FROM THE INSURANCE
FUND. OF THE COST ASSOCIATED
WITH THESE TWO BILLS WILL PUT
PRESSURE ON THE PROPOSITION ONE
THREE SEVEN COUNT OF THE FUND-
WHICH COULD EXPEDITE NEED TO
INCREASE ASSESSMENTS ON
CONSUMERS TO FULLY COVER
INCREASED COSTS. FINALLY THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES-
HAD NOT YET PROVIDED A FISCAL
IMPACT AT THE TIME OF OUR
ANALYSIS BUT WE WOULD NOT
UNKNOWN AND POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT FUTURE COST
PRESSURE IS A CATASTROPHIC
MODELING ADVISORY COMMITTEE IS
CREATED HELLO YES IS REQUIRED
TO ESTABLISH AND OPERATE A
PUBLIC CATASTROPHIC LOSS MODEL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MEMBERS
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS DON'T
COUNTER UP THEN IT WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB. TWENTY ONE SIXTY
SEVEN NOW IS MOVED TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE. WE WILL NOW HEAR
AB TWENTY TWO THIRTEEN OF FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE MON- IF THE
STATE'S SUSPENSE CANDIDATE AND
ON SHE HOUSE WAVES PRESENTATION
SO WE'LL MOVE RIGHT TO PUBLIC
TRUST EMONI ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT I SEE NINE
IN THIS ROOM. NINE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE SEMANA MODERATOR IF
YOU'LL PLEASE PROMPT THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTEEN- PLEASE BEGIN. MAYBE
WE SHOULD. IN THE OF A TWENTY
TWO THIRTEEN PLEASE PESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WINE ONE
THIRTY FOUR IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
MORNING AGAIN JENNIFER
APPEARING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFITS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB TWO TO THIRTY THANK YOU.
NINE THREE FORTY FOUR IS OPEN
TRY DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
LINES AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
THEN WE WILL MOVE TO THE
OPPOSITION AND I SEE NO ONE
HERE IN THIS ROOM NOR IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE SO MARDAM MADAME
MODERATOR IF YOU'LL PLEASE A
PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. OF AB. TWENTY TWO
THIRTEEN. IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY TWO THIRTEEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
CURRENTLY WE HAVE NO LINES AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SIDE YOU HAVE A FILE.
YES THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR WE
ARE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
BECAUSE IT WILL RESULT IN A
GENERAL FUND IMPACT NOT
INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET ACT. TOTAL FOR THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
AND CAL VOLUNTEERS. TO DEVELOP
PUBLISH AND DISTRIBUTE THE
MODEL GUIDELINES ARE UNKNOWN
BUT LIKELY TO RANGE BETWEEN
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
TO ONE MILLION DOLLARS. GENERAL
FUND FOR BOTH ENTITIES WITH
ONGOING COSTS AT THEREAFTER TO
REGULARLY UPDATE AND DISTRIBUTE
THE GUIDELINES ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS. ARE MOVING TO MEMBERS I
SEE NO HANDS UP SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB TWENTY TWO. IS
MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE FILE. ARE
WILL MOVE ON TO AB TWO THREE
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN A SEQUEL EXEMPTIONS.
ARE IT IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE-
AND A PRESENTATION HAS BEEN
WAIVED. SO WE'LL MOVE DIRECTLY
TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY. I DO NOT
SEE ANYONE HERE YEAR AND FORTY
TWO OH THREE FOUR SUPPORT. NOR
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE SO MADAM
MODERATOR PLEASE PROP THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWETY
THREE TWENTY THREE. IF YOU WISH
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY THREE TWENTY THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONE FORTY IS NOW OPEN.
MEMBERS OKAY NOT EXACTLY HOW
PUBLIC AFFAIRS- CALLING ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIAN LEE AND
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT THE YOUNG. ONE ONE
FIFTY EIGHT IS NOW OPEN. SHARE
THIS IS BOB NAYLOR- I AM
REPRESENTING FEELS SEVEN
COMPANY AN ORANGE COUNTY
BUSINESS FOR MORE HOUSING AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AB TWENTY
THREE TWENTY THREE THANK YOU.
NO FURTHER LINES AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVES TO
OPPOSITION ICY NINE HERE IN
THIS ROOM- NOR IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. SO MADAM MODERATOR ON
IF YOU PLEASE PROMPTLY
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF AB. TWENTY
THREE TWENTY THREE. IF YOU WISH
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY THREE TWENTY THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONE NINETY NINE IS NOW
OPEN. THANK YOU WATER MODERATOR
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS KATIE
JEREMY SMITH YOUR GAP OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION.
ONE ONE SIXTY SIX IS NOW OPEN.
I'M SURE NUMBERS KATE ON THE
HIT AROUND THE CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL OF LEAPERS AND
OPPOSITION. YOU NUMBER ONE. ALL.
ACCESS. AND ONE MOMENT PLEASE
FOR A LINE NUMBER. ONE ONE
TWENTY SIX IS NOW OPEN. YOUR
BILL JERK AND SORRY BUT WE ARE
IN SUPPORT AND SORRY FOR THE
TRAINING ON THAT THANK YOU. BOB.
BOB I HAVE A FOR THE LINE TO
THE TIME. THANK YOU WELL THEN
LET US TO DEPART OF FINE I DO
WE HAVE A FILE. YES THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE IN INDICATE
THAT WOULD ELIMINATE WORKLOAD
COSTS ASSOCIATED FEE REVENUE
FOR SEQUEL REVIEW ASSOCIATED
WITH THE PROJECTS THAT QUALIFY
FOR THIS EXEMPTION. THE
DEPARTMENT ADDITIONALLY
INDICATES THAT A POTENTIAL NEED
FOR A CURRENTLY UNKNOWN NUMBER
OF ADDITIONAL STAFF FOR OUT
REACH EFFORTS TO ENGAGE WITH
PROPONENTS ON PROJECT
IMPLEMENTATION IN ITS ROLE AS A
TRUSTEE AGENCY. HOWEVER WE
WOULD NOTE THAT THESE OUT REACH
EFFORTS NOT A REQUIREMENT OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU. YOUR
MEMBERS NO HANDS UP AND WE WILL
MOVE IT TO SUSPENSE WITHOUT
OBJECTION. NEXT BILL UP BILLS
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAR SANTIAGO
FIREARMS DEALERS AND THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE WILL MOVE DIRECTLY TO
OUR PUBLIC TESTIMONY I WILL
BEGIN WITH SUPPORT BY ANYONE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE I SEE
NO NO ONE. ROOM ONE TWELVE I
KNOW WHEN SO WILL GO TO THE
MODERATOR OF PLEASE PROMPT THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY THREE
SIXTY TWO. IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
THREE SIXTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON THE
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. I HAVE NO ONE
IN THE QUEUE FOR SUPPORT PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU WILL NOW GO
TO OPPOSITION ALL AGAIN KNOW
WHEN YOU KNOW HERE IN FORTY TWO
OH THREE IN OPPOSITION- NOR IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE. SO PLEASE
PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB.
TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO. IF YOU
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO A
LINE NUMBER THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FOUR NINE THREE TWO FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS
MICHAEL WITH THE NATIONAL
SHOOTING SPORTS FOUNDATION WE
ARE IN OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT. THIS
ROOM WAS ONCE INVITED BY. WELL
I'VE ALSO CREATION WE'RE STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL IT
HURTS SMALL BUSINESSES AT THE
TIME THEY NEED TO RECOVER THE
MOST THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. I THINK IF YOU
COULD JUST TO REPEAT YOUR NAME
AND AFFILIATION I'M SORRY WE
MAY HAVE HAD YOUR LIKE MUTED
FOR THE VERY FIRST PART. YES
THANK YOU THIS IS REALLY GOING
ON. WITH A CALIFORNIA RIFLE AND
PISTOL ASSOCIATION ALSO
SPEAKING ON BEHALF. OF THE
NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU. THE. I WATCHED AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO OPPOSE AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. IN ONE MOMENT WHERE
AT PROVIDING A LINE NUMBER BE
HUNDRED AND TO PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE ONE ZERO TWO. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS SAM CREDITS
REPRESENTING GOVERNMENTS TO
CALIFORNIA AND AS A LIFE. GUN
DEALER IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO AB. TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO.
AND LADIES IN GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO
CALLS AND- HAVE NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE UP PARDON ME I DO HAVE
SOMEONE IN THE QUEUE FOR
OPPOSITION IT'LL BE JUST A
MOMENT WHILE WE GIVE THEM A
LINE NUMBER. IS A. SEVEN IN
THIS. ONE PERSON IN THE QUEUE
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. AND SO WE
ALL. THE FOOD ROUND OF
PHYSICIANS SEVEN YOU KEEP GOING
I JUST THEY HAVE WHAT WE PERSON
IN THE QUEUE THAT IS LINE
NUMBER THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE
THREE SIX EIGHT. HI I'M CALLING
TO ENCOURAGE APPROPRIATIONS FOR
A B. SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT.
RAT POISON IS WILD POINTS AND I
LIVE IN MARIN COUNTY CALIFORNIA
AND I JUST. YOUR FOR SIXTY
YEARS ALL BUT ALL YEAH GET
ANIMALS DIE ANIMALS AND I'VE
SEEN LEAVE ABOUT AGING OR
SUPPORT. AND WHO YOU REPRESENT.
AND YOU'RE ON THE WRONG BILL
REPRESENTS THE PUBLIC I MOVED
TO ORDER THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM MODERATOR PLEASE MOVE ON
WITH THE OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SHOW OPPOSITION OF AB. TWENTY
THREE SIXTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. THANK YOU. AS
LONG. OKAY I HAVENO ONE IN THE
QUEUE FOR OPPOSITION OF AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO PLEASE
CONTINUE. ALL RIGHT- HAVING
DISPENSED WITH THE SUPPORT IN
THE OPPOSITION WILL GO TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ESTIMATES
GENERAL FUND COSTS IN THE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL
ADDITIONALLY THE DEPARTMENT
ESTIMATES DEALERS RECORD OF
SALE SPECIAL ACCOUNT COST OF
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. ONE
HUNDRED AND ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER WE KNOW
THAT TO THE EXTENT TO THE
DEALERS RECORD OF SALE SPECIAL
ACCOUNT IS UNABLE TO ABSORB
ADDITIONAL COSTS OF THIS BILL
COULD RESULT IN ADDITIONAL
GENERAL FUND COST PRESSURES. TO
BACKFILL THE ACCOUNT. ALL RIGHT
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION. A. B. TWENTY THREE
SIXTY TWO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING TO AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY
ONE BY MR MULLIN. ON OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH. NOW IS
THE TIME. FOR SUPPORT MR MULLIN
HAS WAIVED. PRESENTATION
THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS ROOM IN
SUPPORT THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE. THERE'S MODERATOR
IF YOU COULD KEEP UP THE FOLKS
WHO ARE ON THE PHONE LINE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT AB.
TWENTY SIX TWENTY ONE. AS AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE. OF
EIGHT TWENTY ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY ONE. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THREE SEVEN ONE. THREE SEVEN
ONE. I'M HEARING MYSELF SPEAK
BACK AT MY ON THE LINE IS IT MY
TURN YES TURN OFF THE DEVICE
THAT YOU'RE LISTENING TO US AND
YOU'LL STOP THE FEEDBACK I'M
NOT LISTENING DEVICE I'M
LISTENING TO YOU AND YOU'VE GOT
WRAPPED PEOPLE PLEASING PEOPLE
CALLING. ALL RIGHT. GOOD WE ARE
TAKING SUPPORT. FROM CORRUPTION.
WE ARE TAKING SUPPORT ON AB
TWENTY SIX TWENTY FOUR AM TO
GATHER. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SUPPORT AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY
ONE THIS IS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DO SO PLEASE. MODERATOR
FACILITATES. WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE THREE TWO
ZERO. HI GOOD MORNING STICKBALL
COMING UP THE CALGARY TOWER
ALLIANCE ARE SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SIX TWENTY ONE THANK YOU.
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SIX TWENTY ONE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. NO ONE IN
THE QUEUE YOU MAY CONTINUE. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY ONE- THERE'S NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. I'M NOT A WRITER COULD
YOU QUEUE UP THE OPPOSITION FOR
AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY ONE. IF
YOU ARE TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY ONE. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AGAIN FOR OPPOSITION
OF AB. TWENTY SIX TWENTY ONE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
AND I HAVE NO ONE IN THE QUEUE
FOR OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY ONE YOU MAY CONTINUE.
FANTASTIC I'M- FORMER FINANCE
THANK YOU THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING RESEARCH ESTIMATES AN
ONGOING COST IN THE RANGE OF
THREE HUNDRED AND TWELVE
THOUSAND TWO TRAINER TWENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND FOR THE PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL ADDITIONALLY A WE KNOW
THAT THIS BILL CREATES
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT GENERAL
FUND COST PRESSURES TO SUPPORT
REGIONAL CLIMATE NETWORKS AND
TO FUND THE CREATION AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF REGIONAL
CLIMATE. ADAPTATION PLANS. ALL
RIGHT SEEING NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY ONE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING TO AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY
FOUR. ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS ON
GLOBAL WARMING- HE'S WAY
PRESENTATION THERE'S NO ONE
HERE IN SUPPORT. THERE'S NO ONE
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE- MODERATOR
IF YOU COULD QUEUE UP THE-
PEOPLE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SUPPORT AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY
FOUR. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR A BI TWENTY NINE
FIFTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN IF ZERO. AGAIN FOR SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY FOUR.
YOU MAY PRESS ONE TEN ZERO. I
HAVE NO ONE IN THE QUEUE AT
THIS TIME FOR SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY NINE FIFTY FOUR. ALL
RIGHT WELL GOOD OPPOSITION
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED NO ONE ROOM ONE TWELVE
OPPOSED. MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
QUEUE UP FOLKS WHO ARE OPPOSED
TO AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY FOUR.
IF YOU ARE OPPOSED TO AB TWENTY
NINE FIFTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN. ZERO AGAIN IF YOU ARE
OPPOSED FOR AB. TWENTY NINE
FIFTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. NO ONE IN THE QUEUE
FOR OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY
NINE I DO APOLOGIZE SOMEONE HAS
QUEUED UP WE ARE PROVIDING
THEIR LINE NUMBER ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THREE LINE THREE SEVEN
THREE YOU MAY GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS GAIL BILL HAND WITH WESTERN
GROWERS AND WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION THIS BILL. WE HAVE
MY NUMBER THREE HUNDRED AND.
SEVENTY FOUR NINE THREE SEVEN
FOUR. HI GOOD MORNING NATALIE
KNACKS ON BEHALF OF MIDLANDS
LOW REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS IN THE
RELATIVELY COMMITTEE NATURE
CONNECTION AND CALIFORNIA HAVE
TECH CONSERVATION PLAN
COALITION IN SUPPORT. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WE HAVE SEVERAL
MORE IN THE QUEUE. HAVE LINE
NUMBER THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE LINE. THREE SEVEN
FIVE. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
FOR THE COMMITTEE LEARNED ALL
AND HE TOOK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FRESH FRUIT
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA CITRUS
MUTUAL ANOTHER AB ORGANIZATIONS
IN OPPOSITION TO TWENTY NINE
FIFTY FOUR. MY NUMBER ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE ONE SEVEN
THREE. GOOD MORNING TAYLOR
SHOULD HELP YOU FARM BUREAU IN
OPPOSITION. IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWO NINE FIVE
FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. I HAVE NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE FOR OPPOSITIONOF AB TWO
NINE FIVE FOUR YOU MAY CONTINUE
ALL RIGHT WE WERE GOING TO
FORMER FINANCE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WE'RE NEUTRAL ON
THIS MEASURE AND WE KNOW THAT
THE BILL IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD'S EFFORTS
TO INCORPORATE A NATURAL AND
WORKING LANDS CLINICAL AND
FINAL IMPLEMENTATION PLAN- INTO
THE SCOPING PLAN UPDATE. I DO
IN TWENTY TWENTY TO. ALL RIGHT
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OPPOSITION AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY
FOUR WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING TO AB THREE THOUSAND
FIVE ALSO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS- YOU'D WAY PRESENTATION
THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NOT ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. MODERATE IF YOU TO
QUEUE UP THE SUPPORT FOR AB
THREE THOUSAND FIVE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
QUEUE UP IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
THOUSAND AND FIVE. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AGAIN TO.
SHOW SUPPORT. FOR A BI THREE
ZERO ZERO FIVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE EIGHT
ONE SEVEN FOUR. TO RE OPEN THE
LINE ONE MOMENT PLEASE. NINE
ONE SEVENTY FOUR THE LINE IS
OPEN IF YOU WILL GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MONICA MILLER REPRESENTING
DEMOCRATICALLY WATER DISTRICT.
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS THE ONLY
WATER IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE AT THE SPONSOR'S
MODERNIZE THE COMMITTEE THAT
THERE ARE NO COST WILL BE.
BURDENED ON THE STATE VALLEY
WATER INTEGRATED ALL COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS
LEGISLATION- WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT WHEN IT COMES TIME TO
YOUR SUSPEND THEM THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY. MY NUMBER
NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MODERATOR- MISTER
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH
YOUR BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL SUPPORT. I
NUMBER THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FOUR NINE THREE SEVEN
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING NATALIE KNOCKED ON
BEHALF OF MAINTENANCE LOWER
REGIONAL OPEN SPACE DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR AB. THREE ZERO
ZERO FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. I HAVE NO ONE IN THE
QUEUE FOR SUPPORT ON AB THREE
ZERO ZERO FIVE YOU MAY CONTINUE
THANK YOU WILL GO TO OPPOSITION
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. WATER IF YOU COULD
QUEUE UP THE OPPOSITION TO AB
THREE THOUSAND FIVE THAT WOULD
BE GREAT THANK YOU. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF THE B. THREE
THOUSAND FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'D
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF AB THREE ZERO ZERO FIVE. YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. PROVIDING MY
NUMBERS IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT.
NINE THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE THREE
EIGHT FOUR. THE LITTLE GIRL HI
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
AND THE COURT. SINCE WE HAVE
ONE NUMBER THREE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THREE LINE THREE EIGHT
THREE. HI THIS IS CHRIS
ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES APOLOGIES THAT A
LITTLE LATE GETTING THROUGH BUT
WE WANT TO REGISTER OUR SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL THANK YOU. I HAVE
NO ONE IN THE QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT I BELIEVE WE'VE
DONE SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION ON
THREE THOUSAND FIVE- BERMAN
FINANCE DOUBLE REPORT. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AT THE TIME OF
THIS ANALYSIS THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD WAS
RIGHT IT WAS PROVIDE US WITH AN
UPDATED FISCAL BASED ON THE
MOST RECENTLY AMENDED VERSION
OF THE BILL. THAT WE WOULD KNOW
THAT THE BILL OUR RESULTS IN
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT COSTS
AND COST PRESSURES. ASSOCIATED
WITH THE WATER OR PROVIDING
ASSISTANCE TO THE DISTRICT
IMPLEMENTING A PILOT PROJECT.
ADDITIONALLY THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD ESTIMATES COST
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED NINETY
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND
ONE HUNDRED NINETY TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON GOING. FROM THE AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL FUND. FOR
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH THE
GREENHOUSE GAS DETERMINATION
PROCESS. THE BOARD NOTES THAT
ALTHOUGH THE BILL INCLUDES TWO
POSSIBLE OPTIONS FOR COST
RECOVERY. THAT NEITHER IS
FEASIBLE DUE TO THE RESOURCES
NEEDED TO PROMULGATE A
REGULATION AND THE UNCERTAINTY
OF BEING ABLE TO ENTER INTO AN
AGREEMENT TO RECOVER COSTS.
THAT ARE ABOUT THE AIRPORT'S
USUAL LEVEL OF SERVICE. THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL ESTIMATES COST
OF THREE HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A ONE TIME FOR THE
TRIAL COURT TRUST FUND- AND
LASTLY THE BILL MAKE CREE STATE.
PERSONAL MANDATE. BY REQUIRING
A HIGHER LEVEL OF SERVICE TO BE
PROVIDED BY A LOCAL AGENCY AND
AT THIS TIME IT'S UNCLEAR
WHETHER. IT WOULD HAVE AN
ABILITY TO. BUY THE FEES FOR
THIS PURPOSE. ALL RIGHT SINGLE
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION.
AB THREE THOUSAND FIVE WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE WE WILL MOVE ON TO
AB THIRTY THIRTY BY MISTER
KALRA AYE HE'S WAY PRESENTATION
THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS ROOM IN
SUPPORT THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE IN SUPPORT. BUT IF
YOU COULD QUEUE UP FOLKS WHO
WANT TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY THIRTY ON LAND AND OCEAN
CONSERVATION GOALS. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF A. B. THIRTY THIRTY YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. MY NUMBER
THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE THREE
EIGHT SIX. ON A PLANE HOPE AND
GOVERNMENTAL ADVOCATES RESPOND
TO A CLARA VALLEY OF THE BLANKS
LADY SPEAKING IN SUPPORT.
NUMBER THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SEVEN LINE THREE SEVEN
SEVEN YOU MAY GO AHEAD. THIS IS
MERRY BERRY BEING ON BEHALF OF
DAN GUARD BOND AND THE SILVER
STRAND. PROJECT ON THE SOUTH
BAY AND SAN DIEGO STRONGLY
SUPPORT AT THIRTY THIRTY THANK
YOU. BY NUMBER THREE HUNDRED
AND FORTY ONE NINE THREE FOUR
ONE YOU MAY GO AHEAD. MORE
AFTERNOON FOR FEDERAL ON BEHALF
OF OUTLAND FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY THIRTY. MY
NUMBER'S THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SIX POINT THREE SEVEN
SIX YOU MAY GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS THE FEAR OF THE COBALT
THE PLANNING CONSERVATION
LEAGUE AND WE ARE STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. BY NUMBER
THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FOUR
LINE THREE SEVENTY FOUR YOU MAY
GO AHEAD. FINALLY MAXIM BEHALF
OF LOS ANGELES NEIGHBORHOODS
LACK TRUST IN THE CALIFORNIA
HABITAT CONSERVATION PLANNING
COALITION IN SUPPORT. MY NUMBER
TWO HUNDRED AND NINETY FIVE
LINE TWO NINE FIVE YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. YEAH THIS IS BOB
HERTZBERG CECCARELLI ON WHICH
SIDE IN SUPPORT THANKS. MY
NUMBER'S THREE HUNDRED AND
NINETY LINE THREE. YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBER OF THE KEY TO CROWDED
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL. CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL AND OF WHILE RECOUP ON
DURING BILL WITHOUT AND ON THE
OTHER ORGANIZED THAT ARE
MILLION THE NUMBER CALIFORNIA
TALK OR IF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NUMBER'S THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY TWO LINE THREE. SEVEN
TWO YOU MAY GO AHEAD. HI WHY
CALLING IN SAN DIEGO. IS THERE
STRONG FOR AB THIRTY. THANK YOU.
LADIES AND IF YOU WOULD TO
SPEAK INSTEAD OF AB THIRTY YOU
MAY PER ONE THEN. I HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN THE QUEUE FOR SUPPORT
FOR A BI THIRTY THIRTY YOU MAY
CONTINUE. ALL RIGHT NOW IS THE
TIME FOR OPPOSITION DAY BE
THIRTY THIRTY BY MISTER KALRA.
THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE- MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB.
THIRTY THIRTY. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB THIRTY THIRTY YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. MINUS THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE POINT
THREE SEVEN FIVE YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. IN MOURNING AT YOUR CARE
OF THE- BAR NINE TAKE PAGE
NUMBER HOW OF CAL FRESH THAT
THE- NEED THE FARMERS MAKING
APPS AMERICAN. AND ENOUGH.
THAT'S QUICKER AS LONG. THIS
MORNING AS WELL. THANK YOU LINE
S. THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
LINE THREE SEVEN ZERO YOU MAY
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
THE ONLY GATHERED ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN OPPOSITION. I
NUMBER THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
SEVEN NINE THREE EIGHT SEVEN
YOU MAY GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE BASKETBALL ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE INLAND EMPIRE
UTILITIES AGENCY CUCAMONGA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT AND WATER
REUSE CALIFORNIA ALL IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER'S HUNDRED AND NINE LINES
SIX NINE YOU MAY GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BY
CAPPING UNCH REPRESENTING THE
OFF ROAD VEHICLE LEGISLATIVE
COALITION THE PARK WEB INTERNET.
OUTDOOR SPORTS WHO CALL OF. AND
CALIFORNIA. LOBBY ALL STRONG.
TO AB THIRTY THANK. MY NUMBER
THIRTY EIGHT LINES EIGHT MAKE A.
YEAH A LINE NUMBER THREE EIGHT
WE HAVE A LINE OPEN FOR YOU YOU
WISH TO SPEAK. PLEASE GO AHEAD
LINE THIRTY. HI MY NAME IS YES
WE HAVE YES SORRY I WAS ON THE
SIDE A NEW NUMBER IS ROY
SPEAKING ON THE CALIFORNIA
RIGHT PISTOLS. AND THE NATIONAL
RIGHT SO WE'RE UP TO THIS BILL
THANK YOU THIS POP. EIGHT NINE
THREE SEVEN EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IRWIN COTLER PRESENTING
COCOPAH CONSERVATION
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
MOTION FIVE SENIOR ANGLERS SAN
DIEGO COUNTY WILDLIFE
FEDERATION ALONG WITH HUNDREDS
OF FISHING CLUBS FOR BOTH
SPORTFISHING LANDINGS. RADIO
SHOWS MAGAZINES MANUFACTURERS
RETAILERS BOATING COMPANIES
OUTDOOR RECREATION SHOWS
PODCASTS BLOG SITES AND
THOUSANDS OF PETITION SIGNERS
WE OPPOSE AB. THIRTY THIRTY
UNLESS AMENDED. MY NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND ONE NINE TWO ZERO
ONE YOU MAY GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS MIKE CONROY
FUNDING SO THE COAST.
FEDERATION OF FISHERIES
ASSOCIATIONS AND ON BEHALF OF
THOSE WHO PRODUCE PROCESS AND
MARKET THE VAST MAJORITY OF
HIGHLY REGULATED SHOULD THE
TALIBAN IS CHEAPER CONSUMERS.
DURING THE BILL'S BIGGEST
MEXICAN TO ESTIMATE COSTS WE
OPPOSE AB THIRTY THIRTY IS
CURRENTLY. MY NUMBER THREE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD LINE THREE EIGHT FOUR.
THE BILL HI ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION AND WE OPPOSE THE
BILL THANK YOU. MY NUMBER TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY EIGHT NINE
TWO EIGHT EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
L. COOK ON BEHALF OF IRVINE
RANCH WATER DISTRICT WE
APPROACHED. MY NUMBER THREE
HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO LINE
THREE FOUR TWO YOU MAY GO AHEAD.
A LINE THREE FORTY TWO WE HAVE
THE LINE OPEN FOR YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK. I'M ONE THREE
FORTY TWO. YES PLEASE GO AHEAD
MA'AM. THANK YOU I WAS GIVEN
THREE SEVENTY TWO SORRY ABOUT
THAT- GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON
MEMBERS EIGHTEEN KLEIN ON
BEHALF OF THE CONGRESSIONAL
SPORTSMEN'S FOUNDATION. A
REMAINING OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
ON EIGHTY THIRTY THIRTY THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY NINE AND ONE ZERO FOUR
YOU MAY GO AHEAD. HI WE HAVE
LINE ONE OH FOUR OPEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK STE. THEY HAVE NO
RESPONSIBLE MOVE UNDERLYING
NUMBERS THREE HUNDRED AND.
NINETY TWO NINE THREE NINE TWO
YOU MAY GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
THIS IS CANDOR DIJO GO WITH
LOCAL GROUP ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
BALANCE KERN COUNTY WATER
AGENCY SAN BERNARDINO VALLEY
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT IN
OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTY THIRTY
I'VE ALSO BEEN DEPUTIZED TO
CONVEY THAT THE STATE WATER
CONTRACTORS ARE ALSO IN
OPPOSITION. AND WITH YOUR
INDULGENCE BECAUSE I COULD NOT
GET INTO- SAY THAT- THE SAME IS
A WATER COMPANIES IN SUPPORT OF
AB THREE ZERO ZERO FIVE. THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY NINE NINE ONE TWO NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HIGHLINE ONE
TWENTY NINE WE DO HAVE THE LINE
OPEN FOR YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK. YES VALERIE NARAL ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB. THIRTY
THIRTY. MY NUMBER'S THREE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY EIGHT LINE
THREE EIGHT EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SHE THIS IS BILL SHOULD
ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
SPORTFISHING ASSOCIATION THE
INTERNATIONAL GAME FISH
ASSOCIATION THE NATIONAL CENTER
FIRST. POLICY AND THE TWO
MILLION AND IN THE STATE
OPPOSED. AB. THIRTY THIRTY. AND
WE HAVE LINE NUMBER THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY LINE THREE
FIVE ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS PETER PHILLIPS
MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS- RECREATIONAL BOATERS
OF CALIFORNIA. AND MEMBER OF
THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA YACHTING
ASSOCIATION AND I AM OPPOSED TO
AB THIRTY THIRTY S. CURRENTLY
WORTH. MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY THREE NINE ONE
SEVEN THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE ONE SEVENTY THREE WE HAVE
THE LINE OPEN FOR YOU IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK. WE DO NOT HAVE A
RESPONSE WE'RE MOVING ON TO
LINE NUMBER ET FIVE LINE EAT
FIVE YOU MAY GO AHEAD. MEMBERS
JERRY DESMOND ON BEHALF OF
RECREATIONAL BOATERS OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION TO SB
THIRTY THIRTY UNLESS AMENDED AS
PER OUR COALITION LETTER THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER SIXTY NINE NINE
SIX NINE YOU MAY GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS MORRIS ALONE A LIFELONG
RESIDENT OF MIDTOWN SACRAMENTAL
REPRESENTING P. I SEE WHY A
PACIFIC INTERCLUB YADA SOCIAIS
TIONAL ONE HUNDRED AND SIX-
CLOSE TO NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND ALSO REPRESENTING RBOT
RECREATIONAL BOATERS OF
CALIFORNIA. HELLO SACRAMENTO
DELTA REGION WE ARE OPPOSED TO
SB THIRTY THIRTY UNLESS AMENDED
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER'S THREE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY THAT IS LINE
THREE EIGHT YEAR OLD YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
CAROLYN JENSEN ON BEHALF OF THE
MOJAVE WATER AGENCY AND WESTERN
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
THREE HUNDRED AND NINETY SIX
ONE. NINE YEAH THE WASHINGTON
FIRES ON HIGHLINE AB NINETY I
DON'T LIKE. I DON'T MIND OR-
WE'RE MOVING ON TO MY FOR
HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT LINE THREE
NINE EIGHT PLEASE GO. HI THIS
IS GUILTY HANSON WITH WITH GROW
THIS. AND I'M ON BEHALF OF FARM.
AS WELL WE ARE IN OUR- TO A
THIRTY THIRTY THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER'S THREE HUNDRED AND
NINETY NINE NINE THREE NINE
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M SURE
AND MEMBERS- THIS IS STRONG AND
DOLLARS ON BEHALF OF PACIFIC
SEAFOOD AND THE FOUR HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES THAT WE HAVE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO A BEAT THIRTY
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER FOUR
HUNDRED LINE FOUR ZERO ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
KEREN MEMBERS PRESIDENT JOHNSON
WITH COACHELLA VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT CALLING IN OPPOSITION
OF AB THIRTY THIRTY THANK YOU.
MY NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED AND ONE
LINE FOUR ZERO ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CAN FRANKIE
SPORTFISHING ASSOCIATION A
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING THE
COMMERCIAL PASSENGER VESSEL
FLEET WIDE MAJORITY OF THEM AND
ALSO THE SPORTFISHING LANDINGS
IN SOCCER CALIFORNIA OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER FOUR HUNDRED AND THREE
LINE FOUR ZERO THREE YOU MAY GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU CANDIDATES ARE
GOING TO HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION WINE GRAPE GROWERS
IN OPPOSITION TO AB. THIRTY
THIRTY. AND IF YOU ARE
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION OF AB
THIRTY THIRTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. IN THREE HUNDRED AND
NINETY SIX LINE THREE NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LAWYERS YOU
CAN SIGNIFICANT HIGHLIGHTED
THREE NINETY. MINUTE ANYTHING
GIVEN WORKING. AND NOW YOUR
BACK REALLY. WIRES. ARE WE ARE
MY NUMBER HER AND FOUR LINES
ZERO FOUR PLEASE GOING. HI MY
NAME IS SURGERY NOW IS A MEMBER
OF AND I'M CALL. OR MAYBE
THIRTY THIRTY THANK. I HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE ALL RIGHT WE HEARD
FROM THE SPORT NOT POSITION ON
THIRTY THIRTY LET US HEAR FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I DO
APOLOGIZE HAVE GOT ONE MORE
PERSON AND- I WOULD SURELY HOLD
ON ONE SECOND WE HAVE ONE MORE
PERSON. I APOLOGIZE A LINE
THREE NINETY SIX THREE NINE SIX
THE LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS
LEGALLY CUENTAS ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATED GENERAL
CONTRACTORS OF CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION. WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE
ALL RIGHT TO PARTMINER FINANCE
TAKE TO. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
WE WOULD DOES THAT IT'S
DIFFICULT TO DETERMINE THE COST
FOR THIS BILL GIVEN ITS LACK OF
SPECIFICITY. THERE WILL BE
NUMEROUS STATE AND LOCAL COST
PRESSURES IN VARIOUS AREAS TO
MEET THE GOALS AND FOR THE
STATE SPECIFIC COST PRESSURES
ARE EXPECTED FROM THE BILL'S
GOAL OF HAVING STATE SUPPORT
REGIONAL NATIONAL AND
INTERNATIONAL EFFORTS. TO MEET
THE GOALS PERTAINING TO WATERS
AND OCEANS. SUCH COSTS ARE
UNKNOWN BUT POTENTIALLY IN THE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OR OR MORE TO THE EXTENT
EXISTING RESOURCES AND ALREADY
APPROVED ON INITIATIVES ARE NOT
SUFFICIENT TO MEET THE THIRTY
BY THIRTY GOAL. IN ADDITION TO
THE EXTENT ADDITIONAL LAND
ENTERS LAND INTERSTAGE
RESTRICTIONS FOR CONSERVATION
PURPOSES A LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WILL LIKELY SEE A DECLINE IN
PROPERTY TAX REVENUE. THEREBY
IMPACTING LOCAL GOVERNMENT
REVENUES. ALL RIGHT SEEING
THEIR GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB THIRTY THIRTY. WHO GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING TO A. B. THIRTY
SEVENTY. FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER ON PREEMPTIVE CHALLENGES.
NOW IS THE TIME FOR SUPPORT
THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NO ONE IN WITH ONE
TWELVE. MONTEREY OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE WISHING TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR A BI
THIRTY SEVENTY. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB. THIRTY
SEVENTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT
THE END ZERO AGAIN FOR SUPPORT
AB. THIRTY SEVENTY YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. I HAVE NO
ONE IN THE QUEUE FOR SUPPORT ON
AB THIRTY SEVENTY PLEASE
CONTINUE ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO
IN OPPOSITION THERE'S NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NO ONE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE- MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
WISHING TO EXPRESS THEIR
OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTY
SEVENTY. IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTY
SEVENTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. MY NUMBER ONE HUNDRED AND
FORTY LINE ONE FOUR ZERO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU PETER
LONGEVITY QUALITY CALIFORNIA
CALLING IN THE COURT- THREE
ZERO SEVEN ZERO THANK YOU. I
ONE MOMENT WE ARE GIVING
SOMEONE THEIR LINE NUMBER.
THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD LINE THREE
EIGHT NINE. ANNA KELLY ON
BEHALF OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF A. B.
THREE ZERO SEVEN ZERO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN IF ZERO ON THE
PHONE KEYPAD. I HAVE NO ONE IN
THE QUEUE FOR- OPPOSITION OF AB
THIRTY SEVENTY PLEASE CONTINUE.
ALL RIGHT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THANK YOU ACCORDING TO THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL THIS BILL
COULD CREATE SIGNIFICANT BUT
UNKNOWN COSTS RELATED TO ITS
CHANGES TO THE JURY SELECTION
PROCESS FOR THE TRIAL COURT'S.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ESTIMATES COSTS OF THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
AND THREE HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND TO ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
AN ON GOING. FROM AN INCREASE
IN WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH
INCREASED FEELS. A SPECIFIC
FISCAL IMPACT- AND POSITIONS
NECESSARY TO HANDLE THE
WORKLOAD WILL DEPEND ON THE
VOLUME OF CASES RECEIVED
ANNUALLY. WILL BE SUBJECT TO
REVIEW AND APPROVAL THROUGH THE
ANNUAL BUDGET PROCESS THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT SEING NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION A. B. THIRTY
SEVENTY WILL GO TO SUSPENSE TO
MORE FOLKS. WHEN ONE A. B.
THIRTY NINETY TWO. BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WICKS O SEXUAL ASSAULT.
AND MISCONDUCT- WILL TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT IN SUPPORT
THERE'S NO ONE HERE IN THIS
ROOM THERE'S NO ONE IN ONE
TWELVE. AND MODERATOR FEW COULD
QUEUE UP FOLKS IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY NINETY TWO. IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY EIGHT NINETY TWO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB. THIRTY NINETY
TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
WHY NUMBER
FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHTY NINE
FOUR ZERO EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS PETER ARMORED ARMORED
IN CALLING ABOUT THE BILL A. B.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT. AND I'M
A REPUBLICAN AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND HOPE THAT IT GETS
PASSED THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AS
A REMINDER IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF A BEAT
THIRTY NINETY TWO YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. I HAVE NO ONE IN
THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME PLEASE
CONTINUE. MAYBE. THIRTY NINETY
TWO. CHARLIE YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- TO THE EXTENT
THAT THIS BILL RESULTS IN
ADDITIONAL CIVIL ACTIONS IT
COULD ADD TO THE TRIAL COURT'S
CASELOAD WHICH INCREASES
BACKLOGS AND COULD CREATE A
PRESSURE ON THE GENERAL FUND TO
HANDLE THE INCREASED CASE LOAD
HOWEVER WE KNOW THAT THE COURTS
DON'T TYPICALLY RECEIVE FUNDING
ON A WORKLOAD BASIS AND
THEREFORE LESS THE PARTICULAR
CASE THAT BECOMES SIGNIFICANT
AND CAN BE DOCUMENTED IT'S
LIKELY TO BE ABSORBED. FINALLY
TO THE EXTENT THIS BILL CREATES
COST FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA FUNDING TO SUPPORT
THOSE COSTS WOULD BE SUBJECT TO
CONSIDERATION TO THE ANNUAL.
BUDGET PROCESS. ALL RIGHT
SINGLE HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB THIRTY NINETY
TWO. WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. WE'LL
MOVE ON THE A. B. THIRTY THREE
SIXTY FOR OUR FINAL ITEM. IT IS
A JUDICIARY CMMITTEE-
COMMITTEE BILL OMNIBUS BILL. WE
WILL TAKE- SUPPORT THERE'S NO
ONE IN SUPPORT HERE AND ONE
TWELVE THERE'S NO ONE IN
SUPPORT. MODERATORS OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT.
HE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORTOF AB. THIRTY THREE
SIXTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AND IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB. THIRTY
THREE SIXTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. I HAVE NO ONE IN
THE QUEUE FOR SUPPORT OF AB
THREE THREE SIX FOUR PLEASE
CONTINUE. ALL RIGHT LET'S CUT
OFF POSITION THERE'S NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSED TO NO ONE IN
ONE TWELVE OPPOSED IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE QUEUE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSING. THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE OMNIBUS
BILL AB. THIRTY THREE SIXTY
FOUR. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB. THIRTY THREE
SIXTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE ST
ZERO. AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF THE E.
B. THIRTY THREE SIXTY FOUR. YOU
MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. I HAVE
NO ONE IN THE QUEUE FOR
OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTY THREE
SIXTY FOUR YOU MAY CONTINUE.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL ON THE PART
IN FINANCE. STRUCTURE AYE I
pMEASURE. OH MY GOODNESS. IT'S A
PAGE TURNER YEAH TODAY ALL
RIGHTS- WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
THIRTY THREE SIXTY FOUR WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY FOR BEING HERE THIS
MORNING IN PARTICULAR MY VICE
CHAIR. MS BATES FOR TAKING OVER
DURING THE HOTLY CONTESTED-
TIMES ARE PRETTY SHAPE THAT WE
WILL ALL BE BACK TOMORROW-
AFTER SESSION WE HAVE A-
IMPORTANT TO. YEAH COMMITTEE.
HOW MUCH TIME AS QUICKLY AS WE
GET THROUGH IT MISTER WHAT
KOWSKI. IN A BEACH BUNGALOW TWO
HOURS PROBABLY. PROBABLY TWO
HOURS- YEAH WILL BE BACK
TOMORROW- AGAIN I WANT TO THANK
ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IF THEY WERE NOT ABLE
TO TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO INCLUDE THEM IN YOUR
TESTIMONY. THE OFFICIAL HEARING
RECORD THANK YOU AND WE
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S
PARTICIPATION I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE I KNOW
EVERYBODY'S WORKED REALLY HARD
TO GET US THROUGH THE WORKLOAD
OF THESE UNFORTUNATE HISTORIC-
PANDEMIC CONDITIONS AND SO
THANK YOU AND WE WILL SEE YOU
ALL TOMORROW. AS WE GO TO THE
SUSPENSE CALENDAR THANK YOU
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED. AND.